there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hello there everybody oh my god it's
your flock of cigal shirt i haven't
[Laughter]
the entire [ __ ] show we're supposed
to be talking about good actors
that was a burn
so yeah everybody i'm an actor i'm an
entertainer
and martial arts legend
[Laughter]
okay he's a living action figure
yeah
yeah that's definitely what he would say
yeah
just tell by my build
[Laughter]
i don't ever use stunt doubles to walk
up and down stairs that's a lie
see it's already started it's already
started yeah i'm not gonna do it anymore
zach says love the red jenny thank you i
i realized that i hadn't worn my my red
wig in a while and i figured i don't
know since we're talking about bella
lugosi and stuff like that and it's
vampires and it's red you know and uh
the funny thing about this is that we
didn't really do this on purpose but we
actually recorded a review today for
horror of dracula the christopher lee
like the first christopher lee like
hammer film where he played dracula so
yeah we're doing a whole classic
monsters week this week i guess which we
didn't even really mean to yeah it's
okay it's okay movie
i mean christopher how can you not love
chris really well the thing about it is
the best thing about her about it was
him with him and uh do you had a guy
peter christian peter yeah well see
that's the thing and i'm glad that we
finally got around to doing this like
karloff and lugosi because we did
actually a while back we did a show
about christopher lee and peter cushing
and then for some reason i don't know
why i didn't think of it but somebody
recommended hey why don't you do one
about karloff and lugosi and i'm like uh
yeah duh we probably should have done
that one first
but you know there you go
uh so yeah i watched those actually
there's a couple good documentaries
about both of them shutter has a really
good one called the man behind the
monster which is about boris karloff and
then there's another one on youtube
that's called the gentle monster that
came out a couple years ago that had
like some interesting stuff in it and
then the bella lugosi one i think was
called the dark prince i don't know what
year that one came out but those were
both pretty good i watched those like
earlier today
so there's that whole thing all right so
uh
zach says i know very little about
either of these guys i tried watching
the 30s dracula once and almost fell
asleep um
well the thing about the the 1931
dracula is that one it's based on a
stage play and it's very clearly a stage
play because it's kind of like that's
the early days of cinema
so you were kind of like essentially
you know watching watching a play but
like on film yeah uh so they didn't
really have the whole like cinematic
language like set up yet i loved it when
i was like six or so i still like it i
still really like it i like i like all
the legos they would play it
um on television sometimes way early in
the morning
um
not on
in california well it was still dark
they'd play it
um
before the saturday night saturday
morning cartoons would come on
and yeah yeah because they had they were
playing monster movies like you know
five o'clock in the morning
four o'clock in the morning well yeah
they were probably cheap at that point
right so when i was a little kid i'd
wake up at like five and watch watch
some monster movies
and then they had good monster movies
and then the cartoons would start
at around six that's why saturday is the
best day yeah
when you're a little kid you could wake
up before the sun would come up and but
automatically without even setting a
damn alarm clock and then because you
knew it was saturday yeah it's like woo
like all the fun yeah monster movies
yeah sitting in front of the tv watching
monster movies and eating cereal and
yeah
[Laughter]
and uh no man when you're like six seven
[ __ ] that little dracula was
that old dracula movie was just scary
enough where you could handle it you
know
i liked it
well the thing about it i kind of feel
like
maybe the reason that uh that the
universal monster moves and i'm not
saying that they wouldn't have still
been as iconic uh you know to this day
like if that this hadn't happened but i
kind of feel like what happened is
because they were
so popular at the time like in the 30s
and then after world war ii like it kind
of started going more towards sci-fi and
it was like the universal monster movies
were seen as kind of like old-fashioned
but at least in the united states like
in
i guess like later on like in the 50s
and 60s they started showing all the old
universal monster movies on tv so like a
bunch of little kids
grew up watching them yeah and then that
kind of started like forest ackermann
like started famous monsters of film
land and it's like because you got like
a whole new generation of kids that were
seeing them for the first time and they
got really into them and so i kind of
feel like that really helps like cement
their life frankenstein yeah wolfman
invisible man
uh
they had
some of them were silent
long silent ones like uh
or silent that was converted to to audio
one of them that i remember was like
that was um
family opera
i think i i don't yeah i think that was
converted to
uh to talky i don't think it was a
talkie at first that one [ __ ] was no
the original phantom of the opera was
silent
i think they did another no i think they
did another version of it later like
that was a talkie but the original one
was the island yeah because i know that
movie was remade several times they hate
they patch them together
i think they had the same mostly the
same cast i think they still had all
what's his name launching
yeah the thing about lon chaney is that
you know he was like a massive
international star um you know man of a
thousand faces right and he actually
died fairly young i think he had like
throat cancer and actually bella lugosi
was supposed to be like his successor
you know what i mean like he was going
to be like the next big horror star
which in a lot of ways he was
and i kind of want to talk to you about
um
just the way i kind of feel like of the
two
between bella lugosi and boris karloff i
think boris karloff had a more
successful
career
because he was more
i don't want to say he was necessarily
more versatile like he was a better
actor but yeah
he didn't yeah one he didn't get
typecast in horror movies like he did a
little bit but not to the same extent
and i think that bella lugosi suffered
uh because of his thick accent
for a long time whereas you know boris
karloff obviously was a native english
speaker so he got a lot more roles that
because he could play other things too
like he played criminals and he played
like sheiks and he played now bella
lugosi did that kind of stuff too but i
think that
lugosi's accent once he came to
hollywood really kind of was a little
bit of a detriment because it really and
conversely like his role as dracula was
so iconic like everybody immediately
just associated him with that role that
he couldn't really get anything else and
i kind of feel like that didn't happen
to karloff as much maybe because
he was so
changed for the role of frankenstein
with all the makeup and like all the
padding and the big shoes and everything
like that so it was easier
like when you saw him like playing a
person we might lose the stream there's
a storm going out of there just tell
them
yeah i'm just yeah i mean it might not
be too bad but i mean there's thunder
out there there's thunder and stuff so i
don't really know all it takes is a
lightning strike and we can lose power
yeah but if that happens you know we'll
come back i'll try to come on if we can
as soon as it uh comes back there's only
a power back yeah i mean usually we
don't we lost power i think like on one
of these from a storm but it was only
like a couple seconds and then we had to
come yeah there was a time we lost power
for two days
yeah but yeah i mean that was that was
like hurricane that was a hurricane
so um
yeah what else is gonna say about this
this is i guess it doesn't matter
yeah what was it
something about something about bella
lugosi
he got a slightly type cast but another
thing is that they don't talk about is
that he didn't age very well he was i
think he
he started to look old pretty quick
he was old when he got famous i think he
was in his 40s when he got famous so is
karloff yeah okay i mean karloff was not
and actually i didn't even realize this
until i was watching earlier um they had
both been acting for a very long time
like before their big break karloff was
actually i think he was 43 yeah when he
was in frankenstein which was kind of
his big breakout role yeah but the
difference there's a big they aged very
differently though i mean they did
a bellagosi was a junkie
okay he he was not yeah that happened
later though i mean that did happen a
little bit later
he hit 60 he was he was shot
but then you had karloff he was still
making movies at 60.
yeah actually boris karloff um
he was still doing movies well and the
thing about karloff too was that he
again like
you know maybe not entirely like
bellagosi's fault but karloff just had
more
versatility he got more offers so he was
actually a really respected stage actor
as well like later on like bella lugosi
was in a lot of stage productions
earlier and then went into movies
whereas karloff was stage acting movie
acting and then later went into stage
and tv and stuff like that and so and
obviously like he got really famous
later from doing like the grinch how the
grinch stole christmas and he actually
did because that great voice that he had
he did all that voice over work of like
he would uh you know read children's
stories and he edited horror anthologies
and all this other kind of stuff so he
like had a lot more stuff going on like
as he got older yeah we called him bella
but his he caught his real name was
bayla all right and bailey
he was a stage performer and he really
was became a [ __ ] international
superstar and kind of sex symbol from
dracula oh yeah and
i said it on this other thing recording
we just made
bayla kind of invented dracula as you
know him and a lot of the a lot of the
[ __ ] things about vampires visually
you know that you recognize [ __ ] like
dressing up be a suave the cape
uh
kind of a sex symbol type
thing that was bailout lugosi that
[ __ ] did that all right
that was not in their [ __ ] source
material in the source material what
they were talking about was that they
were talking about nosferatu yeah he was
like he was like a gross old man
basically
yeah a [ __ ] rat
you know a rat demon and an undead rat
demon
that could do all kinds of weird [ __ ]
and bram stroker's stone i see i did say
stroker but i just because that's my
accent
bram stoker
i got a mush mouth
bob stoker um
kind of simplified
what he had what he had heard about
stragoy and [ __ ]
came up with the dracula story there's a
lot of stuff that he left out struggling
are actually cooler than than vampires
they were ugly
but they could do weird things like
have sex with a dead body
and create living children out of that
or undead children they could have sex
with the undead also
like a like a zombie or whatever and and
give birth to an undead child
they could have sex with a living person
and give sex and give birth to a living
vampire
a vampire that had never died
but when they die they become now an
undead vampire there's all kinds of
abilities that they had they were also
sorcerers
they would literally do magic and cast
spells like a like like a wizard
or a witch
so they weren't just and they they were
ugly basically you know it well
depending on what what they were born
from if they were
a stragoi who had had sex with a dead
woman and when what came out of there
wasn't gonna be good looking okay
or two stragglers that were undead
struggles having sex then that wouldn't
be but if it came out of a living woman
it might be good-looking when it came
out you might look like a normal person
it might be closer to what you would
consider dracula to be
so
there's a lot more to the lore
but
the visual archetypes that you think of
when you think of count dracula and all
the other rip-offs that came from that
for a long time and even interview with
the vampire and blacula and all that
bailey lugosi came up well out of that
that's the thing if you go up to
somebody now i don't care who it is go
up to anybody in the united states or
europe or anything like that and say
dress up as a vampire for halloween yeah
if it's a man they're gonna like have a
suit and they're gonna have like the
widow's peak and they're it's gonna look
like bella lugosi pretty much i mean
that's what it's gonna look like so
the fact that he kind of established
that now like i said we and we talked
about this on our other thing which
isn't going up yet but because we were
talking about the christopher lee
dracula which is a whole different thing
which i like that too i like both
they're both very different
interpretations the max shrek [ __ ]
nosferatu is closer to what
stoker was talking about that's closer
to a stragoi
yeah like more more obviously a monster
obviously yeah a rat
creature
undead
evil looking thing
yeah but yeah you want to see a good
stronghold movie see blood vessel it's a
newer movie it's really good yeah i
think what is it 2018 yeah really good
and that's good that was one of the
better like new movies though one of the
better new vampire movies it's got at
least
at least two stragglers i think it's on
i think it's on tubey yeah
the nazis had found a nazis had one put
it on a ship
and uh it gets out
yeah it's a good one
like world war ii
uh john smith said uh karloff made an
amazing film in his old age targets was
that the peter bogdanovich one yeah i
think so in which he pretty much plays
himself and uh slasher fred points out
boris karloff is also in the original
scarface that's true from the 1930s he
was so yeah that's the thing i think
boris karloff and i know and i kind of
want to get into this a little bit
because i think that
especially after uh tim burton's movie
edward came out
that that really kind of fueled
uh the rumors that bella lugosi and
boris carlos hated each other there was
like a big rivalry between them
um
that seems to be not entirely the case
now i think that bella lugosi was
probably rightfully so
um
professionally jealous because boris
karloff got more
roles than him and like had a lot more
like had a bigger career i guess
uh so i think that he was that but he
didn't have he didn't seem to have any
animosity toward boris karloff he knew
that it wasn't boris's fault
that he was getting more work he just
was just kind of like man that sucks
that he got more work because of the
popularity you could take him places you
know
bayla at the time all that [ __ ] was
going on he was he was a drug addict
you know people they they knew it
everybody knew he was a drug
yeah i mean the public it's interesting
too because bella lugosi was actually i
don't know if you guys know this but he
was actually the first
like hollywood celebrity
to come out and admit that he had was a
drug addict and had been to rehab like
i'm not saying that it didn't happen
before that because obviously it did he
broke the table but he broke the taboo
about it and came out and talked about
it now he was yeah he was in rehab for
three months and actually when he came
out they said he was 74 when he came out
but they said he was actually in pretty
good shape like you know he still looked
like an old man obviously but he seemed
a lot better and he was like actually on
tv and stuff like that but he didn't
live too much longer after that yeah and
it's it's kind of like sad what happened
to him because
you know he kept working up until the
end
you know more or less but like i said he
kind of ended up in like ed wood movies
and
[ __ ] like that and then was like a drug
addict whereas boris karloff i feel like
as he kind of got into his old age he
was a lot more distinguished like i said
he was still working in the theater he
was still doing a lot of voice over he
was doing like editing like horror
anthologies and things like that so i
kind of feel like he got a lot more
respect like into his dotage i guess
yeah uh whereas bella lugosi was kind of
like seen as i don't know if i'd seen
say
seen as like washed up but
he didn't really
he didn't command the respect he didn't
get the same respect i think that boris
karloff everybody knew he was which is
sad because they were both like
amazing actors according to [ __ ]
interviews that i saw over the years is
that it was common knowledge in
hollywood that
baylor was strung out would work for
short change he was at that time he was
he was he was an addict you weren't
going to get any big gigs
just didn't want him around you know
he wanted somebody who was who could
hang you know who could hang with the
drugs were a [ __ ] huge [ __ ] faux
pas back then you know what i mean it
wasn't the hollywood of today where
you could be addicted to something it
was okay no not really well in fact and
it's kind of sad too because back then
uh you know he
it was prescription drugs he got
addicted to because of injuries and then
he started taking morphine and then he
just started taking yeah so yeah
so yeah it's kind of sad how that
happened but like i said he's not the
only one that happened to but you have
to kind of give him respect for being
having the balls to like come out and
like be the first hollywood celebrity to
admit that
um you know yeah and he would talk to
the papers you know
and there's this good there's a good
scene in
the ed wood movie if you guys haven't
seen ed wood you must see it it's a
[ __ ] must-watch movie i mean it's
yeah that's an amazing movie it's
probably my favorite tim burton movie
but um it's all in black and white now
about all hollywood now a lot of the
stuff that they say about because i
think like bella lugosi and boris
karloff's kids like their relatives were
kind of like yeah
that's not really what happened or
that's not really like they didn't
really like the way lugosi was portrayed
it's like he really didn't hate boris
karloff
but if you go into it with that like
don't think it's just like an absolutely
true story then it's an amazing right
it's so [ __ ] good yeah but there
there evidently was some accuracy
because when he was in rehab
evidently people were like man you maybe
you shouldn't be talk you shouldn't talk
to the press about all this and he's
like no
uh no i [ __ ] first of all this is
publicity yeah any publicity is good
publicity but people like the truth and
the truth is is that there's drug
addiction in hollywood yeah and that's
really any and he
he was in his 70s you can't punish a man
in the 70s yeah
okay and he was breaking the taboo he's
like there's drug addiction in hollywood
and you guys have to [ __ ] you know
be forgiving of these people you know
what i mean [ __ ] people need help
with drug addiction and you know
evidently uh
the the public was sympathetic because
they liked baylor
yeah they were like yeah well [ __ ] and
he evidently told his story to the
newspaper that he got addicted to
painkillers from some injury or
something and yeah yeah we'll never
shake it yep
and that's the thing it's
so i i think that was really ballsy of
him because he was really the first
big actor that had done that everybody
else they're trying to keep it oh no one
has drug addictions right none of that
is going on they were everybody thought
that actors and actresses were prim and
proper and that they were like the
paragons of virtue and that they were
things people that you saw on the big
screen and they were role models that
was the old way yeah i mean the studios
definitely tried to portray them that
way so anything any kind of scandal like
if anybody was [ __ ] around with their
wife or somebody like accidentally
killed somebody in a hit and run or that
or a drug addiction or anything like
that they would absolutely try to cover
that [ __ ] up and it was
it was [ __ ] because even going all
the way back to the golden era and the
silver screen
even pre-golden era silent films
a lot of those girls came from of course
professions they were you know what i
mean where the [ __ ] woman had to make
money okay that happened
the first concept of the star
in
western or in the american culture a
star was a hooker
who was given a star at a brothel
because she could sing and dance
okay because hookers don't want to be
hookers they want to be
entertainers
you know kind of like a geisha so that's
where even the word star came from
uh and then you know even the silver
screen actresses especially when they
were new into the business they were all
in [ __ ]
wines [ __ ] what's his name weinstein
that's his name yeah you know weinstein
studios they were in weinstein type
situations you know
yeah that's what i mean there's nothing
new about it i mean like humans are
going to human i kind of feel like the
entertainment industry those girls going
back thousands of years has always been
like that it's always been like that
casting couch and those girls were
passed around between executives to make
sure that they had good careers and [ __ ]
all right
and uh they had to do what they had to
do and then sometimes they were almost
basically literally pimped out to rich
guys
it helped their career that's what they
would say this will help your career
he's going to finance your next movie
but yeah
you blow him he does you he [ __ ]
coughs up ten thousand dollars to make
the new [ __ ] silent movie we're gonna
make that's literally what was happening
yeah i'm pregnant yeah
well yeah every i think everybody knows
that now i don't think anybody knew that
at the time pretty much still like that
that's what i mean it hasn't changed so
i think like people talk about it
nowadays like it's i'm like it's not any
different you know what i mean it's just
they were better at like covering it up
back in the old days because they didn't
have the internet right um so oracle
said judy garland could have done with a
bit more honesty regarding the drugs the
studio made her take yeah that's true
because that man that poor girl and they
got her addicted on [ __ ] when she was
like a kid
like a teenager because they didn't want
her to get fat yeah they wanted to be
thin
and and nimble and they wanted her to
look as young as possible for as long as
possible
yeah that's not possible no not with the
technology that they were using that's
not
that's that's what's sad about it is
that and especially if you got kind of
sucked into it at a young age like judah
garland did
um
you know you really can't it's hard to
like bust out of that yeah to be honest
and really what's what sucked about it
is that for weird reasons
i guess the the tastes men's tastes
in women
back in that time was kind of like
japanese or chinese taste they liked
real skinny
and small for some reason
and
because that's all they saw
on the screen they liked it even more so
it was like a never-ending cycle it's
like a vicious cycle
and you showed them somebody who's
voluptuous or muscular they'd have liked
that too so they didn't have to look
that way
it's just that the studios thought they
did well the weird thing okay look at
what's her name may west may west was
what you would call big fine today
you know today you call that big fine
or thick
and she was [ __ ] sexy uh for her day
the women really didn't look like that
big boobs [ __ ] yeah and i think she
kind of got a pass because she was so
funny funny so i think sexy yeah that's
what i mean well and and i think that
the funny helps the sexy yeah you know
what i mean she wasn't just like a
little injunu right with her big wide
eyes and her little right she was just
like she had like a personality yeah she
was like larger than like that was like
one of the first white girls this is
back in the 30s that's basically on the
slick saying no i date black guys yeah i
mean she did yeah we should probably do
a show about her too right
i love him
sideways comments and she's always
accompanied by her big handsome muscular
black chauffeur
you know that was her [ __ ] boyfriend
yeah yeah everybody
well we have to tell everybody you're my
show first yeah yeah but everybody knew
yeah everybody knew well that's what i
mean it's like people like did know it
was just like about bella lugosi's dream
between the lines everybody
in hollywood knew about it right but
they didn't like tell the public
about that kind of stuff because they
thought that nobody would go see the
movies if these people were just like
people
you know what i mean yeah well her
comedy routines
said a lot of the [ __ ] that she was she
uh her comedy routine was openly [ __ ]
sexual and she was a sexually aggressive
type woman and then she made a lot of
[ __ ] sex jokes so they made fun of
dudes for being inadequate she and then
she she just did a lot of funny [ __ ]
that's what i mean they did it within
the framework of what was acceptable in
the 30s and it was barely acceptable in
the 30s she knew how to [ __ ] walk the
line but no mae west was the [ __ ] man
she was [ __ ] hilarious
well the cool thing about that the
original bad girl you can get away with
a lot in comedy because you can say
stuff that's true but then you're joking
but then you can kind of just like back
off and be like hey man i'm only joking
what's the matter like you know what i
mean so
you can kind of get away with a lot if
you're a comedian yeah uh oracle said
mae west did a lot of charity too she
was rags to riches and didn't forget
where she came from yeah uh and susie
okay said awesome way to go may she did
her [ __ ] and didn't care yeah i kind of
feel like she was one of the coolest
ladies of uh the golden era of hollywood
she was kind of uh there was a lot of
cool ladies back then but i think may
west was probably the her her um
public persona and they made weird
movies in the 30s where the movie's
happening in a nightclub and it's going
from one table to the next everybody's
famous and they're all telling jokes oh
yeah yeah i don't know what kind of and
then there'd be people dancing cabaret
and then
they had weird movies like a variety
it's almost like a variety show but like
in movie format it's a movie form right
i've only seen a few of them and they're
actually kind of good
yeah they are entertaining yeah
and uh she'd be in those things some
[ __ ] real low-cut dresses and looking
good her and wc fields playing [ __ ]
pool together
and hurt
her saying [ __ ] sideways jokes and
[ __ ] just
real good real good
she was uh
her public persona was that of kind of
like gangster girl
kyle yeah somebody the mob would love
you know she was like that
she was a bad girl yeah but she wasn't
dumb she was good she was looking high
quality high quality she's just wild
birth 1930s wild nowadays you just go
yeah okay jesus is cool
back in those days a lot of she was
doing would be unacceptable but people
don't realize that 20s and 30s was
another sexual revolution
and when they think of sexual revolution
you think of the 60s now that happened
in the 20s too well it's cyclical it's a
cycle right it usually happens every 30
40 years or so
same kind of thing like you know
everything gets real wild and permissive
and then like everybody goes oh we can't
have that and then that thing is super
conservative again and then they you
know then it all repeats all over again
i've seen it happen a few times in my
lifetime yeah so the barrel
the barrel gang you know with cl bonnie
and clyde they were
20s and also [ __ ] wild [ __ ]
clive clive barrow was [ __ ] bisexual
and pretty open about it and that was
the 20s
you know so like i said it's always just
kind of like
i don't know just i remember like
talking to my grandmother about this
kind of stuff because she's like you
know no one was gay back in the old days
i'm like grandma really like it's people
just didn't talk about that's what i
mean it's like all kind of [ __ ] like
that was going on back in the day they
just didn't talk like you didn't hear
about it that's all there's nothing
different
about people nowadays 20s and 30s
nothing different it's just you hear
about it more than you did back then
back then that was very scandalous to
like talk about anything like that
so
[ __ ] man you couldn't even until the
1950s right you couldn't even show like
married people sleeping in the same
[ __ ] bed you couldn't even show a
toilet when alfred hitchcock put a
toilet in psycho like in the bathroom in
the shower scene people flipped the [ __ ]
out oh man civilization's falling apart
show the toilet yeah
like you were like you could do you
could have a toilet in your house
obviously hopefully but you couldn't
show it
it's like you're allowed to poop but you
can't tell anybody that you poop it was
that kind of situation and it's just
kind of like that is just so so funny to
me that kind of stuff
i've that's what i mean that's why i'm
saying like i like a lot of things about
you know i like a lot of stuff about all
different eras like i like you know
universal movies i like stuff from the
50s i like storm the 60s but
i don't really like this whole attitude
of we're not all human beings and we
don't all like do this kind of [ __ ] like
i don't know i i'd much prefer when
you're just like open about stuff you've
had a lot of comments you might want to
catch up on yeah i'm trying to uh jane
mansfield was a fascinating character we
should maybe do it maybe we should do
like a
maybe we should do like a whole like
golden ladies of hollywood or i don't
know something like that because you
know i just feel like that's something
we should do because i love that kind of
stuff jane mansfield was actually like
really interesting and zucia said she
liked jane
mansfield better than marilyn monroe
but yeah
um let's see where's to do yep no gay
people in hollywood ever lol yeah never
happened yeah what gay people in
bodybuilding ever that's what i mean and
it's like well that's the thing like you
only found out like you
for example like the first thing that i
thought it was like rock hudson like you
know nobody knew that rock hudson was
good well everybody in hollywood knew
but like nobody in the public at large
knew that rock hudson was gay until
later on and then they're like yeah he's
got aids or whatever and then it came
all out about it but
it's just i don't know that seems really
dumb to me and like i said i'm really
happy that nowadays you can just be
whatever and it's like people are like
okay fine but back then you had to like
really keep [ __ ] secret you couldn't
man like some of the actors back then
that were gay they had to like marry
actresses and stuff and it was like they
had to have a beard and all this other
nonsense i'm like jesus christ i can't
imagine like what that must have been
like just to have to constantly pretend
you were someone else just for your job
that must have sucked you know what i
mean
but yeah
uh yeah tammy said you couldn't even say
diarrhea on tv in the 50s honestly i
still remember
uh commercials from the 1980s and even
maybe into the 1990s where there was
like a commercial for for example uh
like maxi pads like always maxi pads or
something and they still were using the
blue water in the thing
recently i saw a commercial for maxi
pads or tampons or whatever and they
actually used red water and i was like
hallelujah they're finally [ __ ] doing
[ __ ] it's like that's exactly what it
would look like it's not [ __ ] blue
long time listener sass is asking was it
jane mansfield that was involved with
anton yeah sounds familiar yeah
yes she was also involved with howard
hughes
when she was young
i think howard hughes decide or tried to
design a special bra for her for one of
the movies
that's right i think we did a show about
howard hughes and i think i brought that
up yeah that he was trying to trying to
get support that would [ __ ] lift them
and yeah
i laughed but that's a pretty important
yeah i mean you didn't have that [ __ ]
back then that's what i mean and uh
laugh if you want about [ __ ] hughes
howard had multiple head injuries and
which [ __ ] been there uh but then he
also kind of had ocd and uh some some
other things a lot of pressure on him
he ended up going crazy drugs had a lot
to do with it too
but he was a brilliant
engineer
and he was just tutored at home how to
be an aeronautical engineer and a
structural engineer he he was
he was a rich dude
he
i wouldn't say he was born with a silver
spoon in his mouth but he got his dad's
money and then he'd like [ __ ]
multiplied it 10 times
with a bunch of real wise purchases
i would have loved to have [ __ ]
had the opportunities that [ __ ]
hughes had
it didn't make him happy though he'd
walk away from it and go disappear from
his empire where the [ __ ] howard we
don't know where [ __ ] howards is you
know and he'd show up later you know
living like a bomb been gone for a year
you know i mean everybody's got their
own
it's like you can never know like you
look at somebody else's life and be like
man i want that life like i would do
this that and the other thing but you
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on in
that person's head you don't know like
what they've been through you're not
that person so like you don't know
howard was a great race car driver uh he
could race he could fly airplanes great
pilot uh engineered a bunch of stuff
came up with ideas for heat seeking
missiles later on
uh knew about jets and [ __ ]
ultrasonic stuff
um
he had a [ __ ] high-speed world war
two airplane he was working on it was
kind of like a p-38 lightning with
you know uh [ __ ] two fuselages and a
centralness cell with [ __ ] counter
rotating props and it was going to be
bad it didn't make it in time for the
war but it was going to be really good
it was kind of like a p-38 lighting
uh
hughes aircraft came up with a bunch of
really cool [ __ ] and he bought rko
pitchers
and that's how he bought rko pitchers i
think when he was in his late teens i
remember her early 20s and he did it so
he could date movie stars
and he would hire movie stars and never
let him make movies just date him
sometimes then he got where he just
hired him and then never dated him he's
like collecting them like he's a
collector she's wondering when she's
going to make her first
when she's going to make her first movie
she never will he's just got her in a
damn apartment [ __ ] waiting for two
or three years a movie never happens all
kinds of things like here you just stay
in the closet like you stay stay in the
box stay in the box he was a [ __ ]
woman collector yeah forget about it he
would forget about them
it's like collecting star wars action
figures right because you have to keep
them in the box to keep their value now
he did some real important [ __ ] and this
is the weird thing this is the [ __ ]
biggest impact howard hughes ever had
he had his own private security company
to keep
an eye on all these women that he was
hiring okay and to do other [ __ ] for him
he would only hire mormons uh for a
bunch of reasons he liked mormons he
said they were real trustworthy
those guys did everything they could to
fight the fbi because they were
protecting hughes from the fbi because
the fba was trying to put fbi was trying
to put [ __ ] um
bugs
in his [ __ ] phones and do all this
counter espionage [ __ ]
howard hughes's security apparatus
was the [ __ ] blueprint for all modern
intelligence agencies in terms like the
fbi and the cia and everything
they they had to up their game and they
they modernized because of hughes
security
and his security would be like the
[ __ ] model security agency
and counter intelligence agency for the
[ __ ] world he was looking
quite a man
oracle said jenny i thought the same
thing tampons and pads are for menstrual
blood we all know it admitted right
exactly
that's the blue stuff i know and they
use that for diapers and stuff too which
it's like you know i know they don't
want to be gross and everything like
that but come on
uh john smith said would still be hard
for a gay leading man in hollywood now
i.e allegedly hugh jackman and other
confirmed bachelors yeah but
cares well no but i'm not saying that
it's not it's well especially if you're
like an a-lister it might be kind of
harder than like but
it's not anything like it used to be
like back in the old days you couldn't
even like have any whiff of anything
that you might not be totally
heterosexual like i said communist like
well that too but and we'll get into
that because there was a little bit of
that with bella lugosi and a little bit
with boris karloff too because they were
both kind of more leftist union kind of
people so they kind of got in trouble
with that but um
yeah the whole thing about that was like
some actors back in the old days
um they would the studio would make them
marry somebody they would legally make
them marry somebody so nobody would and
they have really had to keep everything
on the down low which must have been
exhausting yeah exhausting i can't
imagine how do you compensate a woman
for that
see that's what i'm saying it's like
well what they would do now i don't know
if this happened a lot but i know that
it happened in a few situations like
because i've written about
uh a couple true crime cases like where
like an actor got murdered or something
and if that actor like the actor uh they
thought he was gay but they would they
married him off to a actress that was a
lesbian okay so basically they were just
kind of like they would match them i
don't know if they did that all the time
but i know they did that in a few cases
where they're just kind of like hey
she's not gonna get married and you're
not getting married so why don't you
just marry each other
and then do whatever do whatever you
want but it's like don't let anybody
like take a picture of you doing it type
of thing yeah you think you'd run out of
lesbians
i don't know about that i don't think
you'd run out i think i think
i think gay men outnumber lesbians
well i wouldn't know what i don't know
i don't know i don't know numbers i
don't know what the numbers were like
back then
and what they considered a lesbian
well they're just sometimes they would
consider [ __ ] weird
well like i said maybe it's just like
women that didn't were maybe not even
necessarily lesbians but didn't really
have any interest in getting married or
anything like that or any kind of like
you know conventional kind of [ __ ] so
they're just like why don't you just
legally marry this guy and then you can
just go do whatever you want as long as
as long as nobody sees you right i kind
of feel like it was probably that kind
of situation yeah i'll pay you a certain
amount you can live here and you can
date you do whatever you want i think
that's mostly what it was yeah i yeah i
think that's probably what it was but i
mean the studios back in the old days
you know it's not the same now but the
studios back in the old days had an
amazing like uh amazing amount of power
over the actors because a lot of the
actors like particularly in the golden
era they kept them under contract like
so
you couldn't you couldn't just you
weren't like a free agent you couldn't
just like go and do movies for another
studio you had to do this many movies
and they kind of had control over your
whole entire life they're like you're
not allowed to be in public doing this
that the other thing and you know and in
california they had an amazing amount of
power over the police and the court
system that too they covered up murders
and all kind of everything yeah they
covered up murders all kinds of murders
they could [ __ ] help with elections
they did everything they were almost
kind of merged with the california state
government and its law enforcement
apparatus
and then that that got bigger in world
war ii when hollywood and the federal
government joined for uh for the
purposes of fighting world war ii
which a bunch of [ __ ] happened there too
and the only [ __ ] stipulation the
feds gave hollywood was keep that commie
crap out of the damn movies
and they did because a lot of the people
that were in the movies
and behind him were communist
but they said if you can merge with us
if you just keep that out of the movies
and during world war ii was nothing but
[ __ ] war propaganda
and then afterwards it was peace
propaganda to get all them damn savages
to [ __ ] get a job at a damn factory
and settle down and have kids in a
[ __ ] house and pick a fence because
those twos were too dangerous to just be
left running around
that that's a whole nother story right
there and they knew all about it i've
seen the documentations there's whole
[ __ ] programs about it how to
re-civilize those dudes after world war
ii and bring them in and make them
disappear
uh i was going to read some uh
let's see hold on
who just said it i just saw it and now i
can't find it
oh he said oh uh john smith said uh take
in that liberace denied he was gay until
his time praying yeah yeah yeah i was
nine years okay yeah i mean you know
we've tried to keep the dream a lot like
i said that's kind of like sad though
that makes me really sad it's it's like
that you just have to deny like [ __ ]
personhood your entire life that's like
really shitty if you're new to the show
and you haven't listened to the other
shows you've mentioned liberation quite
a bit because that was actually evil
knievel's hero
uh he [ __ ] even couldn't even love
liberace
everybody knew his gay but liberace
would never admit to being gay
because all his fans were
middle-aged and older overweight women
who [ __ ]
loved him and he did not want to let
them down and i respect that i resp i
respect it he did not want to let his
fans down although those [ __ ] would
have loved him anyway they were on [ __ ]
hag status anyway i mean it wouldn't be
better he was just trying i think they
probably knew oh i'm sure they did i'm
sure they did but they they were in they
were in the cognitive [ __ ] dissidents
they were in a [ __ ] fantasy
they were in a fantasy that one day
liberace
might [ __ ] love them you know
but no man it's like well i'm gay but
for you you're so special that i'm
making an
that's i kind of think that's what
that's like a certain type of fantasy
sure yeah yeah and i don't think it's
that unusual like i said it's not weird
a lot of people have that
um danny rowling said frankenstein's
monster is way cooler than any vampire
and he's green great color yeah i'm
gonna say
i don't know i really don't want to like
pit these two against each other but i'm
kind of like
i'm less of a vampire person i do like a
lot of vampire movies you would think
like being all goth and everything that
you'd be more into vampires but to be
honest i'm kind of more into the
frankenstein movies although the the all
the dracula ones are good too i'm gonna
say that and i like boris karloff
just in my personal opinion i thought
boris karloff was hotter but they're
both kind of they're both hot
it's just like i said it's kind of like
a christopher lee peter cushing
situation both of them are hot i don't
know they're all hot
is that weird no
all of them are hot
i don't know if i can rank them i think
they're all cool i mean you know what i
mean i you know i'm not attracted to
them
i am i like that
of course i like that kind of thing i
told you one of my earliest crushes i
know some people think this is weird one
of my earliest crushes when i was a kid
was um
ted cassidy the guy that played lurch on
the adam yeah yeah she told me that
that's funny
yeah that was i was like super into that
yeah like that one episode where he's
like where uh wednesday is teaching him
to ballet dance and he has like a tutu
on yeah i was just kind of like oh my
goodness
i don't know why i got so into that but
i was just kind of ridiculous
i know but it's like hey
the heart wants what it wants i'm just
saying it's just like i was into that i
still think he's like i know he's dead
now but um yeah i was like i don't know
i'm like i'm i like that
big tall cadaverous corpsey thing i like
that i don't know why i don't know why
but um
i guess well i guess cause i'm a horror
girl and i like a lot of that horror
kind of iconography so i always thought
i always thought boris karloff was super
hot plus he has like that voice and he
just looks like that he's got that great
head like that
weird looking face i love that [ __ ]
karloff is that karloff i would have
never known it but he's half indian his
dad was from india
uh he i don't think he's half indian
he's more like a well a coordinator i
thought his i thought his mom was
they're both british empire people yeah
the mom his mom
his mom i think was half indian
okay oh and maybe his dad was also happy
do you know i can't remember i've got it
like written down in there because uh
they went on that
he was very dark as a child i saw
pictures of him as a kid early on he got
a lot of roles that were what were
considered like ethnic roles yeah like
if when we have this dude and he's not a
white guy you gotta play him he's okay
so there's a lot of that kind of yeah
it's like hey we gotta we have a like an
arabic or whatever yeah
yeah we got a mexican guy you're gonna
play that you know she's like okay so
that was that was his first jobs
but he was a great actor
and
really he could look like anything you
you know you dressed it up right i never
would have thought i just thought he was
a british guy
he didn't look indian to me
but you could make him look indian or
you could make him look [ __ ] real
anglo-saxon it didn't matter
he was a good actor for that i mean what
a great [ __ ] face that dude had well
you kind of had the comments kind of
like
like a greek or a roman statue you know
he had a real strong nose
he kind of had a he looked like he
looked like he looked like an emperor or
something like a roman emperor yeah it
was just a very very distinctive like
face that he had yeah you know what's
crazy and i think i just learned this
today because i guess i always perceived
boris karloff as being
taller
than bella lugosi
that is not the case bella lugosi is
actually taller okay uh bella gossi was
actually i believe six foot one
yeah i guess it was because i'm so used
to seeing boris as frankenstein's
monster and they put like those big
lifts in his shoes and like made him
like real big and hulking i mean he was
a big guy but he wasn't i think bella
was a little bit taller would be like
five seven five eight no it's like i was
actually surprised about that too
because he's actually much bigger oh you
know what's crazy i was just watching
like right before we did the show i was
watching a documentary on youtube about
uh bellagosi
and they have his son
um you know who's a grown man now
obviously but he's like talking about
his dad and he was talking about like
all the roles that his dad played like
on the stage and stuff and he's like oh
and um bella lugosi played
jesus and he was like the best jesus
like in this theater production like
company that they had and they had like
photos of it and i'm like oh my god he
makes a great jesus he looks really good
okay like all the all the um photos that
they have them just like he had like the
crown of thorns on and the hair and
everything like the beard and i was like
holy crap he looks fantastic he looked
really really good i thought he he made
like a really good jesus because when
you say that like it sounds everybody's
so used to like seeing him as dracula
but when you see
um because they had all these publicity
stills of him from other roles that he
played on the stage like when he was
much younger
and
in some of them you wouldn't even unless
you looked really close you wouldn't
even really know that that was lugosi
you know what i'm saying because
everyone so associates him with like the
dracula look when he was actually like a
little bit older yeah as i said before
he was actually actually
lego st was a [ __ ] stage actor that's
where most of his work was that's where
his
that's where his
character was built
and evidently
as he got older he always um
thought of himself as a stage actor and
would remember those times because
that's
that's where he was built you know and
that's where his
that's where most of his time was done
yeah i mean
that's just
that's karloff started out like that too
so yeah
cessp says my first crush was rocky
horror's frankenforder men and makeup
just do something for me yeah also hot
uh also hot tim curry in that um
lars ulrich said oh i've been meaning to
watch this there's a movie called the
sorcerers it's free on youtube one of
the last with karloff might be the last
i don't know if it was actually because
i know that they released some like
posthumously like after he died but that
might be less is that william freaking i
want to say that's a william freaking
movie same guy that did the exorcist but
um yeah i've been wanting to see that
actually
zach says oh [ __ ] carlos aunt was the
chick they based the king and i off of
yep that's true
uh oh that's right yeah yeah that's
right right yeah so because it's great
that's a great [ __ ] movie it is yeah
i really like that i mean if you guys
haven't seen the king and i but you old
brenner you'll [ __ ] love it it's a
musical it's really good yeah
i mean the thing about english teacher
who goes to [ __ ] siam which is a
country no longer exists i think it's
probably thailand by thailand or myanmar
yeah thailand and try to teach him how
to be civilized and speak english and
[ __ ] and your brother plays uh the
king of siam and all kinds of [ __ ]
happens it's good and in the end they
get married they get married which is
based on something that actually
happened and that was that was called
zombie carl left that yeah yeah yeah
that's his mom's sister yeah i think
um
[Music]
sagitta is that you pronounce your name
uh or sejita like sagittarius uh i loved
them all but i think my favorite is
vincent price i mean vincent price is
also [ __ ] awesome i just all of those
guys i love all those guys
um let's see
john smith said my first crush was a
puppet kira the gelfling from dark
crystal make up that one
i remember that i get it like [ __ ] yeah
she was pretty cute and she kind of
looked like a person yeah when i was a
kid when i was a kid he used to think
those things were cute too but you you
see them recently and they just don't
look these don't look like anything
other little puppets they actually kind
of look low quality well they are little
puppets yeah i don't know if i'd say
that that's that was jim henson man that
was like top of the line i saw him quite
recently though and they they i was like
man they don't look as good as i
remembered them looking in terms of
quality the skeksis looked pretty good
though
i still like those these sketches
looked really awesome although that it
was everything it was a very repetitive
movie i couldn't get through like the
first 20 to 30 minutes i had to turn it
off
the dialogue was really repetitive of
chanting sing-songy
maybe i could make another run at it but
i tried to yeah she might have been in a
bad mood yeah i tried to watch a dark
crystal again and i could only got about
20 minutes into it well we started
watching it again because remember like
didn't like netflix did that series like
a continuation of it yeah which
evidently didn't do well
even though like a lot of people seem to
be talking about it like when it first
started
uh sarah says the tingler great movie by
vincent price yeah we reviewed that not
too long ago i think it was just like a
couple months back we talked about the
thing i have to say my favorite price
movie would have been um i am legend
i had to see it again or last man that's
been on earth yeah it's based on i am
left but yeah it's um i mean vincent
price was good in everything yeah i
probably say a house on haunted hill but
i don't know he was in so much good
stuff that it's kind of hard to say kind
of hard to say
uh all right so are we ready to get into
this oh i had a couple we're into this
well we are kind of but we haven't even
got into the biographies or anything
like that yet so
uh i had a couple shout outs
i think we mentioned this on the matinee
show yesterday but i wanted to mention
it again on the main show uh thank you
to louie
for sending us the steelbook edition
of sicario
yeah which we really need to review yeah
i've watched it and the second one
it's just that we never reviewed it yeah
we'll do it so we will do that oh and
also i want to give a shout out to our
patron liam who increased his patronage
oh great this week thank you so thank
you very much for that we do have a
patreon patreon yeah if you're
interested and if you go on our patreon
you can
one i tell you like what all the shows
are that are coming up that week um also
for my scarcity crime immemorial thing i
started like adding that in there too
and you can vote on
the topic for whatever the next week's
uh show is and the movie for the movie
retrospective so you can vote on those
as well and of course super chats are
active you can drop super chat right
there in the damn comment section and i
have a twitch that i just opened twitch
account it's called uh tom 13 o'clock
and um i've been playing some video
games we've had some people pop in
it's usually in the what i would
consider to be the the morning time or
the afternoon time that i play i've been
playing
um
right now i'm playing um tomb raider
tomb raider legend and after that i'm
gonna play
anniversary and then i'm gonna do
underworld which is that's classic too
it's classic tomb raider stuff um you
can drop chats to me
live and we can talk and uh i got
headphones on with the damn microphone
so we can talk live
and uh because there's less people
following i think there's maybe only
like [ __ ] 20 people over there
uh i can talk about things over there
that i can't talk about here i don't
want channel get banned
because i gotta watch out for the
[ __ ] business you know some of it but
i've had some decent questions asked to
me
over there about uh [ __ ]
current events and stuff and what i
think okay
let me go get another uh legend of hell
house actually legend of hell house now
that you bring that up is easily one of
my favorite films in the 1970s easily i
mean that's a great [ __ ] movie i love
that movie so much and the book is good
too if you haven't read it it's just
called hell house by richard matheson
who is again like one of my favorite
horror writers
so all right so let's get into let's
talk about bella lugosi first because
that's just uh happened that he was the
first one that i put in my notes uh i
wasn't going alphabetical or i guess i
went alphabetical by the first names not
their last names so you know
so all right so bella lugosi that's
obviously not his real name although he
is
and i'm sure i'm gonna butcher this
because uh his actual name is bela
frank french
desso blasco so his first name is
actually bayla it's bayla um even though
a lot of people just say bella because i
think he lost the little accent lugosi
actually he got that last name because
the town that he was born in
in hungary uh was called lugosh so he
was just like naming himself
after the town that he came from like
leonardo da vinci or whatever
so he actually grew up in a pretty uh
middle class family like middle class
upper middle class in hungary
so his dad had started out as a bakery
and actually like baker and like ran a
successful like bakery business
and made quite a bit of money doing that
uh his dad's name was it's van by the
way
and so he decided well i made a lot of
money doing bakery stuff so i'm gonna
like try to move up the ladder i guess
so he invested in like a savings bank
uh and kind of set that up with him and
a few partners and they actually had a
really successful banking business so he
set that up in the late 1800s uh which
is right around the time when bella
lugosi was born
so uh the thing about it though
is that bella's dad was real
uh strict and was real very like
conventional he was very kind of like
you know he was very successful in the
bakery trade and the banking trade so he
wanted his kids to go into and i guess a
lot of parents are like this but um you
know he's like i want my kids to go into
like a trade or something where they're
gonna be successful and make a lot of
money i don't want him doing weird [ __ ]
or anything like that and he was very
very much like that
so um bella though
he seemed like uh he's very intelligent
but he just didn't really like school
um he was just kind of more of a
unstructured person he was much more
into like singing and theater and all
this other kind of stuff which obviously
his very strict father had absolutely no
patience with
uh they said at one point and this is
from a biography of his
they said in school once they asked him
what job do you want to get when you
know in the future when you grow up and
he said i'm going to be a highway bandit
so you know what i mean it's not not
great so like i said he was just very
into like theater kind of stuff he was
like the guys are like that i was a
better school kid i was like that yeah
uh so his dad was like jesus christ
really so there was that there was a lot
of like friction in the household it
seems like
now interestingly though his dad
died suddenly when bella was just 12
years old
so this is hardcore i mean
bella
left home at 12. damn
um because you know his dad was dead i
couldn't imagine 12 years old i don't
even remember being 12 years old that
was a long time sure i was a human being
at 12. that's what i'm saying most
people weren't yeah the fact that you
would actually leave home at 12 he's
like well you know my dad was dead so i
had to go get a job and like try and
support the family 12 years old right
so
so he walks
300 miles uphill in the snow i don't
know i'm adding that detail
to like the nearest industrial city and
just got jobs it's like he worked in a
mine uh he worked on a railroad it was
he did like all that kind of [ __ ] like
when he was a [ __ ] kid like 300 miles
sleeping on the side of the road
probably did yeah 12 years old i can't
imagine like
nobody would want a 12 year old kid to
do that nowadays what country was this
again romania
yeah well um hungary hungary yeah
yeah that's where he was born that was
deep deep back in the old school honky
motherland that's how they did [ __ ] back
then man that was like that was the mis
that was mississippi of europe okay i
understand you just did what you had to
do
i mean the man of the house was dead
and so you were the next oldest son i'm
imagining so you're like well
i'm only 12 but yeah
[ __ ] like that was probably normalized
then anyway that's what i'm saying it's
like yeah it sounds like a big deal to
us but yeah i'm sure it happened lots
but that's the thing it's like everybody
you just yeah and it's not like
you know it it's easy to like look back
on it now from our like cushy modern era
yeah where you know you don't have to do
that thankfully but it's like back then
that was just oh well you just had to
buck up and do it because you didn't
really have a choice you know what i
mean yeah those days can come back
they can come again yeah i'm not saying
that but i'm just saying that
you know i'm not saying it wasn't
hardcore because it was but i'm just
saying that a lot of people probably had
yeah it was it was culturally normalized
because it's easier to suffer in mass if
you're in the army
suffering on your own is pretty bad if
you're yeah with [ __ ] thousands of
your [ __ ] friends you're all being
punished for the [ __ ] sins of the
fathers or whatever the [ __ ]
battalion commander says [ __ ] you it's
easier to suffer in mass than it is so
when you see other kids doing it and
everybody else is doing it you're like
it gives you permission to do it well
because i think that a lot of the
depression and stuff like that that
comes out of bad circumstances
is when you're in bad circumstances and
everybody else seems to be doing okay
so it's just kind of like you're seeing
all this like why can't i have that so
there's like some resentment and like
wondering what you're doing wrong so if
everybody is in the same shitty
situation then yeah it's shitty but it's
not as shitty because you're not
comparing yourself everybody's doing
shitty so you don't feel as bad because
you're not comparing yourself you know
what i mean i yeah i've kind of seen
like yeah so it might not have been
like that like back in the old days but
yeah
so he's 12 years old and he's working in
mines and railroad and stuff like that
for several years i guess like when he
was a teenager now when he was 18
apparently his sister uh who i guess was
a little bit older
now she was married and she got um bella
like a place on like a traveling theater
troupe because that was what he was
really into and that's what he wanted to
do
so he actually started acting on the
stage in 1902
so as far as they know like his earliest
known performances like on the stage
were with kind of just little theaters
here and there like in 1903 1904
somewhere around there and he was in a
bunch of plays he was usually small
roles like little operas and stuff like
that and then like later on he would go
on and do uh shakespeare he was in like
in a lot of shakespeare plays as well
now he actually moved to budapest
in 1911
and actually got a spot with the
national theater of hungary so he was
there for several years from 1913 to
1919.
now although it's very and i've seen
other i saw roddy mcdowell on um
talking about was it ronnie mcdowell or
it was somebody no it wasn't rodney
mcdowell it was um
what's that actor's name ray walton i
think his name is brian mcdowell was on
the boris carloff documentary but ray
walton was talking about being in
something with uh bella lugosi and he's
like bella lugosi would always say
i was uh what did he say i was like the
cary grant of hungary's royal national
theater or something like that that
doesn't appear to be the case he was in
a [ __ ] ton of plays around this time
period but he wasn't
um
i don't know if he was like
famous throughout the region or anything
like that but he wasn't a [ __ ] he's just
known he was known like in that area but
they it was like small roles supporting
roles i don't think he had any leads or
anything like that bailly knew what he
was doing you yeah you don't sell
[ __ ] steak you sell the sizzle right
you know that means like man back in
back in hungary i was the [ __ ]
yeah
of course that's what you do everybody
knew who i was everybody knew i worked
it's like they're not gonna check so
yeah right as well
yeah but yeah so
there is kind of a thing where it's like
yeah he was like the most famous like
i'm the john barrymore of like or
whatever and they're just like
he was in a lot of stuff i'm not i'm not
like trying to discount but they you
know he was kind of like blowing it up
and i think he knew that he was too
so then world war one comes along and he
was actually uh in the austria
austro-hungary army uh from 1914 to 1916
he was an infantryman and then uh got up
to lieutenant yeah and he got a medal
for like he got some uh wounds while he
was on the russian front so he's got
hungarian mel for that actually a
[ __ ] proud empire was around for a
long time
right before right but
right before you know world war one
happened
and [ __ ] like a dozen empires
a lot of them [ __ ] centuries old all
vanished one of them was austro-hungary
austro-hungarian empire but they were a
good army and a in a decent empire
so
him serving there's an infantry
lieutenant that's no mean feat yeah
that's that that's good real good
they were a good outfit
yeah so he was there for two years like
he said he got wounded on the russian
front got a medal for that yep
then he goes back to
regular life and then started acting in
hungarian
silent films
now
that actually a few of these do survive
um he wasn't going by bella lugosi at
that point he was going by the name
aristide alt
um he went under different pseudonyms
like before he actually like established
himself like i said and i don't think
you were here when i said it but uh the
last name lugosi came from the town that
he was born like the name of the town
was lugosh yeah so that's where he was
just like
paying homage to the town that he was
born at english names mostly have to do
with jobs being a porter a smith [ __ ]
like that a lot of other latin based
names have to do with where you're where
you are from where your last place you
were from that's what i said just like
leonardo da vinci yeah [ __ ] like that so
that that's just because da vinci was
not his last name that was right that
was where he was from his name was just
leonardo yeah he didn't have a last name
that yeah that's where a lot of last
names came from i'm not like really
fascinated by that i love that kind of
like i love that stuff but when you
think about it
it's elevated slang
pretty much yeah yeah pretty much yeah
yeah
so you'd be like
jenny from deltona jenny from daytona
i'm from daytona danny from daytona i
mean it's not there's only like jenny
daytona yeah that'd be some sexy ass
latin [ __ ] d daytona
[Laughter]
that's my that's my fancy renaissance
artist name
[Laughter]
[ __ ] yeah it's like daytona it sounds
real like i said continental but you
actually go to the place and it's like
oh my god this is like a redneck [ __ ]
hole well it's not that bad no it's not
that bad it's not that bad no more it's
not as bad as what i got that's the way
it was decades ago it's a racetrack with
a with uh the downtown area and uh
suburbs
and a lot of housing uh there's there's
also new housing complexes that have
sprung up in the last few decades they
were nice they were kind of like the one
we just left
yeah you're like that lots of those
but yeah i mean you know when i was
growing up there it was like it was
hitting there in those days yeah not not
much no
like i said it was all country bars
right so there's that yeah zach said my
ancestors from norway had their last
name come from the farm they were born
on i kind of feel like that was mostly
kind of the thing it was either your job
or
where you were from yeah so like i said
bella goes he was just honoring that
because that was the name of the town
that he came from and his name is uh you
know very hard to pronounce like his
actual birth name
for for people like us
now after that uh he actually had to
flee hungary
because as i said he was a very like a
left-wing sympathizer and when hungary
like i guess the communist government
took over like the they were trying to
do like the communist revolution and it
got defeated
so he was like yeah i gotta get the [ __ ]
out of here i'm gonna get assassinated
or executed or whatever so he took off
um in 1919 so he actually went to vienna
and then he went to berlin
and then he started acting in german
silent films now uh during this time
period his first wife of
counting five that he had over the time
of his life not judging boris karloff
also had five wives it just uh it
happened back then so uh his first of
these are popular men yeah you know well
in bella lugosi
bella lugosi um according to his
relatives and friends and like people
who knew him that i've seen like
interviewed they said yeah he was a
realist particularly when he was younger
he was a real ladies man but they said
he was a they said that he was a lovely
lovely person but in relationships he
tended to be very very jealous
and he tended to be very um domineering
so sometimes like women that couldn't
hang with that
they'd be like yeah i don't like this
situation and they'd be like taken off
it's an eastern personality yeah yeah
yeah they said they said he was very
very jealous like you'd like the woman
like talks to another man he's like oh
no oh [ __ ] we're not having that yeah
we're not having that so a little bit
like that but but i mean everything else
like people said that but they were like
he was like a good dude like he wasn't
you know he wasn't a shitty person or
anything but he was a little bit like
that
so uh his first wife at this point like
after he went to germany uh his wife
left him and went back to her parents uh
and filed for a divorce so like i said
that was the i think that was the first
of his eventual five lives
so at this point bella comes to the
united states on a merchant ship like he
worked on a merchant ship i think he was
like an engineer
in 1920 he worked his way over to the
u.s
and he landed in new orleans
and eventually worked his way up to new
york city
1928 he declares his intention to become
a u.s citizen and in 1931 he was
naturalized as a us citizen
now as i said he arrives in america look
he's six foot one which like i said if
you see dracula i always thought he was
a shorter [ __ ] yeah i was
thinking he's not six foot one yeah it
doesn't look that tall
yeah six uh they said when he first got
here is six foot one 180 pounds that you
know so that's kind of that's kind of a
big dude in those days that that's huge
that's a big dude he was a big you know
in those days that's huge
especially for an eastern european
that's huge
yeah so he was a big [ __ ] so when he
has standards at 6'4
because [ __ ] average heights have
gone up
amongst
amongst you know like caucasians you
know well better nutrition better you
know childhood uh health things like not
so much against [ __ ] like you say
central americans and stuff you know
you know me coming up and [ __ ] south
america you know central america maya
type people they're short
and you know
average age average height in the united
states is going down because so many
central americans are moving in those
little short little dudes man i can't
hate i am five three i'm five
i am also five foot three yeah so right
not to not go down to the mexican
restaurant here it's a real mexican
restaurant and i see these dudes from
damn nicaragua and [ __ ] el salvador
and [ __ ] coming in and some of these
dudes i i feel huge and i'm
i'm five foot six i feel [ __ ] huge
these dudes are like five feet tall with
some of them
they come here to work on these farms
and
they're just short man
short little dudes well like i said
there's not a lot you can do about it
yeah like some height things yeah it
does have to do with
uh you know childhood nutrition and
things like that but a lot of it's
genetic to be honest i think i think in
central america you know with the maya
and the aztec and everything is uh had
to do with basically selective breeding
you know they were
well accidental selective breeding they
were sacrificing all their best people
to [ __ ] you know
cancer coddle and [ __ ] certain times so
they took the tallest ones first so
being shorter meant you were least
likely to be [ __ ] executed to be
extra sacrificed so it's probably better
to be short yeah it's better to be sure
now [ __ ] we got caught out of that
salon i don't know if he's in here now
he's my buddy from tijuana he's like six
too
all right he is truly con [ __ ]
you know what i mean big [ __ ]
big mexican you know and they do have
some
but
probably you know [ __ ] royal
bloodlines that [ __ ] you know
because everyone every central american
i see here you know when you go
mexico broke up in a bunch of parts
you know and some of them were ended up
being el salvador and honduras and
nicaragua
those guys were all short
pretty much
like i said no shame of being short
because yeah i am also short yeah so i'm
not going to they're shorter than us
we're talking it takes a lot like to be
shorter than me because i'm pretty
[ __ ] short
um
john smith said actors never lie about
height i'm totally convinced tom cruise
is six foot two yeah yeah yeah you
cracked that too right i just wear his
height releasing trousers yeah yeah yeah
people i'm telling you people i've tried
to figure out how tall tom cruise
actually is i'm five six i think tom you
need to meet him in person and make sure
that he doesn't have any lifts in it
he's going to have magic shoes on and
everything but i i stand next to him and
then we'll discover yeah i'm pretty sure
tom cruise is about my size probably
five six
i'm pretty sure
yeah and like i said there's no shame in
that that's so silly
it's like just tell people he has good
physicality he's and he's a [ __ ]
great actor that's okay no one's gonna
care he's actually delivered man his
movie's still out there playing making
money
[ __ ] uh top gun too is still out
there making money
anybody that would care that it's like
well i'm not gonna go see tom cruise's
movie because he's only five foot short
i go see it's just like you don't need
those people's money anyway right yeah
so don't worry about it seriously yeah i
mean
so yeah i love you tom
[Laughter]
wouldn't it be funny if tom cruise is
watching and he comes in it would be
love you too it wouldn't be it wouldn't
be as funny as if steven seagal was
watching this that would be hilarious
now steven seagal is [ __ ] big
yeah i'm not yeah i'm not [ __ ] on
steven seagal's height because yeah he's
big he's big yeah
but he's not the martial artist [ __ ]
people he claims and if he keeps going
the way he's going he's going to be as
big around as he is tall so he's going
to be as wide as he is tall so i'm just
saying he's swimming in whole pools of
asian experience [ __ ] energy drink
we're having an eating experience
i love you too baby yeah i won't have
asian experience me and you but
that [ __ ] commercial is awesome do
you know how much a can a sealed can of
asian experience goes for on ebay how
much 120
holy [ __ ] yeah and they had to do to
open one up and drink one and he says
it's gone bad yeah that was on city
massacre yeah it's pretty bad that guy
that's on there it's not james but it's
like the other guy that's on there all
the time with the glasses 120 he's a big
fan of like steven seagal and he
actually like bought that and drank it
yeah and then drank one and it had gone
bad i'm sure it probably tasted like ass
like even when it was fresh because well
you don't like energy drinks i don't
like energy drinks they all taste like
they all kind of taste like pot sweet
tarts that's what i mean they always
taste like gross like sweet like sweet
tarts that somebody has kind of like put
in their armpit that's kind of what it
is like the worst one that was the rock
star cranberry everybody hated that one
i still liked it
i liked it i can't imagine
zach says it's weird with tom cruise
he's attractive as [ __ ] but i'm not
attracted to him i don't know what it is
that's not weird um i don't i'm not well
it's like arnold arnold's like that well
yeah that's the thing it's like being
good looking and being like sex sexy or
like sexually attractive that's two
completely different things that's two
completely different things i can admire
somebody it's like oh yeah they look
like aesthetically they look nice
but i wouldn't do them just it's like
they're not attractive to me
even though i admit that they're good
looking i'm not saying tom cruise is
ugly he's not yeah but he's not sexy
i don't think he's like arnold arnold
was always a good looking guy he had a
fantastic body
but arnold knew that he wasn't really
sexy um
although there were a lot of women that
[ __ ] liked him of course you know i
mean but there's just
something about arnold schwarzenegger
that
doesn't evoke sexuality
best with with the most women you know
um
although i saw some photographs from
predator one
of behind the scenes where he's grabbing
the girl you know the girl that was from
the moon anna
they were taking a photo together yeah
and she obviously was just totally into
[ __ ] arnold and that was quite a
quite a sexy photo but it was a
behind-the-scenes photo yeah of them
like i'm sure some people aren't gonna
like obviously some people find him sexy
yeah i'm just saying that like i don't
it has to do with the way he's shot and
filmed and the the and the the
characters that he's playing in the
movie it's just that in the movie he's
not sexy
but evidently in person he was
some of those women that married him
said that he was at that he was
addictive
that if you were around him that's what
i mean it's like it's hard to like
translate because it's like you know you
don't you don't know them so it's like
in real life yeah they might be super
sexy because you like right but like i
said that's why it's hard and especially
for women i think because we're less
generally less visually oriented usually
you have to like know a person
and it's like then it doesn't matter as
much what they look like like you know
if even if they're weird-looking it's
just kind of like if their personality
is awesome then that'll make them like a
lot more attractive to you yeah um so
there's that like john smith said i
thought this was kind of funny famously
nicole kidman after voice divorcing tom
cruise was asked what she was looking
forward to and she replied wearing heels
again yeah ice cold i'm like oh my god
oh what a bird i like nicole kidman what
a bird like that was so [ __ ] i love it
he wouldn't let her wear heels that's
ridiculous yeah i'm five six and i it
doesn't bother me if jenny's [ __ ]
and she's short of that he's not yeah he
is i don't i don't have an issue but you
know what's funny is that i'm not gonna
name any names i got a friend that is
yeah he doesn't let her wear heels
i was like which is crazy i was like
what the [ __ ] you like heels yeah i
don't even like to wear wear heels
because they're uncomfortable i never
had an issue with it because but i have
big platform boots and i have some
platform boots that do make me taller
than him sometimes and he has never ever
love it
i love it he loves them uh it's just uh
i never had security never had that
insecurity i guess to me it was always
like
a status symbol like i felt like a
goddamn big game hunter you know what i
mean [ __ ] i'm like yeah look when i
landed she's sick feet you know
i brought down a whale you know what i
mean
but uh i get and i think that happened
in high school i dated a swedish girl
who was like six two but no one would
date her in high school
well girls that are really tall not tall
yeah they really have a lot of problems
because i had a i had a friend in high
school that was six one six two and she
had a [ __ ] [ __ ] of a time yeah
feet like huge feet like feet like a
[ __ ] bigger than a man's feet that
was the only thing that was weird about
it and that was up in brazil when i was
in international high school and she was
like six two she's from sweden she was
sweet mad cute
good body smart girl swedish girl um
huge
and i gotta say that yeah
it took some getting used to it was
weird
but you're a teenager you're just lucky
to get some [ __ ] you know what i'm
talking about but it's just
i didn't have that
sizest
i think to be honest with you i think
the dudes that complain so much about oh
girls don't take me because i'm too
short are too hung up about being short
and that comes across like that
insecurity comes across and that's
what's turning people off i don't think
it's your shortness that's turning
people off i think it's your insecurity
about it that's true we knew dude we
know a guy i'm not going to name names
he was shorter than [ __ ] me he was
maybe five one or five two
and his girlfriend she ended up dying
later on at yet a young age from a brain
tumor
she was about six feet tall
yeah she was way taller than i was yeah
and she was dating him
and the only thing wrong with him is
that he he was just [ __ ] know it all
and just [ __ ] to drive you [ __ ] the
only thing wrong with him is that he's
kind of a douchebag that's what i meant
he was a douchebag know it all
[ __ ] stop it and i think that i kind
of feel like he's one of those dudes to
be like oh girls won't date me because
i'm short i'm like no they're not dating
you because you're a douche but they
were dating him
but i know i'm just saying that he seems
like somebody that would give off that
yeah they were dating him and [ __ ]
these
and okay
based on things that [ __ ] have
happened to me
from an early age and based on what i've
seen in other short dudes even dudes
shorter than me a lot of them end up
with really tall women
because
women who are real tall are in a worse
position than a guy who's short yeah big
time yeah
nobody dates them nope
it's [ __ ] sad they can be gorgeous
they just won't date him because they're
just too tall
and uh he was picking up on all the tall
ones this little shirt [ __ ]
and um
that's weird yeah i've ever really had i
never really had that mental hang up
oscar said the friend tom is referring
to his little swole no it isn't no not a
little small no it isn't no little
little little school is not uh it's not
a douchebag
he's actually like a really really great
girl he's really cool and uh he
he was dating
a a tall girl
who ended up she went down to australia
for a while she was a mensis
menta mensah yeah yeah
real a genius chick stacey that
she was a weirdo but i was into it yeah
she was like a door she was like a hot
dorky real hot dog which i like that
yeah i like i like hot chocolate dress
and [ __ ] and then like
she would disappear for a while and then
come back but they were dating for a
while
it was just no but little swole is
actually kind of cool
he's not a douche at all
he's actually really awesome he just
needs help with diet
because he can't eat anything he's a
super taster and he can't eat anything
that has flavor
and he can only eat things that are
white
yeah
he's toasting spaghetti pretty much all
the time yeah spaghetti and rice and
um his favorite flavor is butter
that's his favorite i mean no shame
butter is delicious
he can't even eat any meat but he thinks
he might like
he might like um lobster because he
smelled it and it smelled like something
he would like i was like look if
seafood's smelling good to you then
that's something we can work with right
but then he never so he's extremely low
protein
and i'm like dude man we're gonna have
to get you on hrt we're gonna have to
get you on [ __ ] steroids you gotta
start [ __ ] eat drinking protein he
drinks protein
okay
but his diet is [ __ ] up
and a little swole i call him little
swole but he might be my size
is he my size or shorter you think
he's about the same height as you maybe
an inch shorter but it's not a huge
it's not a huge difference
yeah
i can't like because usually when we're
hanging out with him usually i have my
big boots on he's probably like my
height i don't know like maybe he's an
inch or two taller than me and like i
said i'm five foot three
so if he's an inch or two taller than me
then he's probably like an inch shorter
little likes all those old cheesy 80s
karate movies [ __ ] you know uh
even though he's younger than us he's
younger by quite a by quite a large
margin he loves [ __ ] sylvester
stallone [ __ ] he loves
[ __ ] uh
seagal um
i can um dude who did the octagon what's
his name and chuck norris john norris
and
just octagon was actually one of the
better movies yeah if it's cheat if it's
cheesy 80s [ __ ] he loves coming he
[ __ ] loves it
well honestly like one me and him well
sometimes because you and him get off on
action movies but he's real into like
old horror movies too so if i get him on
that like we'll just talk for hours and
hours like he's like super enthusiastic
about which like i said i love that i
love like people that'll go all like
dorky about horror movies with me
um but yeah we're getting way off topic
again zach says whereas daniel craig is
kind of weird looking but i think he's
hot as [ __ ] yeah daniel craig uh is way
way hotter
than uh arnold schwarzenegger or tom
cruise or anybody like that like daniel
craig is way [ __ ] hotter way [ __ ]
hotter but like i said i'm
i like weird looking it's not
necessarily weird looking because that
sounds bad but it's just like i like
distinctive looking if you look too good
there's something like sterile
about that you know what i mean like if
you're
you've had a bunch of plastic surgery
and you look like and i'm just saying
like yeah aesthetically that looks good
that is pleasing to look at
but
it doesn't like stand out in any way i
tend to be like more attracted to
people men women whatever that are
kind of weird looking or that or that
like stand out that are like distinctive
looking like i said some of my first
questions going way back some of my
first crushes were like horror guys like
i was into like peter cushing i was into
the dude ted cassie that played lurch i
was into that kind of stuff like if
they're weird-looking um
that's kind of more my jam
and i wouldn't even call it like
weird-looking but it's just kind of like
like i said distinctive they have their
own thing going on you don't confuse
them for somebody else i kind of feel
like if you're
sort of like
uh you know a big a-list kind of star
and like there's a particular look like
depending on whatever the era is that
you're watching the movie from there's a
particular kind of look that was like
really popular at the time so you had
like a lot of like a-list stars that
looked like that but a lot of them just
look the same to me so i can't really
i'm just like which one is that now
you know what i mean i kind of like
what i like weird-looking people i like
weird-looking people because that it's
distinctive you're like
sticking out like i said there's even
something hot about somebody like steve
buscemi like yeah he's
ugly kinda but
i don't know there's something like
still kind of hot about that you know
what i mean because
you're not gonna confuse him for anybody
else that's for sure and that's uh not
gonna happen with some of the other kind
of like bigger a-list stars who
sometimes i can't tell one from the
other because they all get the same
plastic surgery so there's that
so where was i we were so like not even
a quarter of the way through this [ __ ]
this is gonna be like oh my god this is
gonna be such a long show
and i'm just like
i don't want to get too much into it but
i'm last night after the show um
i kind of got
sick and i'm not going to say like what
it is because it's tmi but uh yeah so i
was like i'm i'm feeling better today
but i'm still kind of like what time is
it it is one it is uh 7 25. okay look at
one thing i can tell earlier what in
about a half hour go down there and down
pull that chicken out
and uh
season it and put it in the oven and
slow cook it okay well you can do that
yeah we might have to do that in a while
that way it's done by the time we get
out i got a [ __ ] whole chicken i'll
put that thing in the oven
oh that sounds good yeah remember i got
the whole i got two of those whole
chickens oh okay i had one of them out
thon
i gotta cover it with some oil and
clean it off cover it with some oil and
put some spices on it and put it in the
oven let's only take a second okay okay
rebecca says oh god i just noticed tom's
t-shirt yeah i bought him that did i buy
that for christmas or your birthday or
something like that like a year or two
ago that was a long time ago that's just
it made me laugh so much i'm like oh my
god i have to get that yeah uh danny
rowling said who would win in a fight
frankenstein's monster or count dracula
dracula dracula probably would because
he has more i mean frankenstein's
monster is just i mean let's be fair
he's bigger sure but he's just like a
corpse that was reanimated with
lightning he doesn't have paranormal
power he doesn't have paranormal powers
whereas dracula does so i'm just i'm
going to give it to dracula even though
like i said i kind of like the
as far as the universal movies go i
think i like the frankenstein one
slightly better but
they're all good and honestly as if
we're talking about boris karloff i was
really into him as the mummy too i
thought he was like super hot as a mommy
i was like i was into that i thought
that was honestly the frankenstein
makeup is iconic and that's amazing like
the jack pierce did but
for my money i think the mummy makeup i
think i like it a little bit better like
as him as an imhotep i think
oh man he looks like so [ __ ] great so
you got this for a minute uh yeah i'll
be back in about five minutes all right
so yeah so bella gets to the u.s like i
said he worked his way over on a
merchant ship uh because he really
wanted to come here
so he worked and this actually was boris
karloff did this too which we'll get
into in a little bit like you just did
what you had to do back then so he just
uh worked as a laborer pretty much
because he was a big dude and you know
you just did whatever had to be done
like to make some money
and then like he gets to new york city
and his english was not great when he
first got here i've seen different
sources some people said like he could
speak absolutely no english
uh some people said that his english was
very broken like he could make himself
understood but that's about it so at
first um he kind of like went into the
theater world in new york city but he
had to
basically find jobs within the hungarian
immigrant community like in that theater
so there's that
so what he did at first rather than
trying to break into
english-speaking theater i guess was he
got together with a couple of other
hungarian immigrants and they formed
their own uh stock theater company so
they would kind of like tour around
playing for other immigrant audiences so
they would do stuff that was not in
english you know what i mean because you
know that was what they were more
comfortable doing
so uh bella lugosi actually acted in a
bunch of uh hungarian plays
and then he actually got a role in his
first english speaking broadway play
which was called the red poppy and that
was in 1922.
now
as i said i don't really know how much
of a command he added the english
language at the time
some people have said he learned all of
his lines phonetically
uh so i've heard that uh
you know so it might have been that he
kind of understood what he was saying
but i've seen some sources that he
didn't have any idea like what he was
saying in the play uh he just learned
the lines phonetically and said them and
he wasn't aware of like didn't have any
understanding of what was going on
but
regardless uh his performance was still
good enough to like really get noticed
so apparently he was like kick ass
because
even though he couldn't really speak any
english
like he still like [ __ ] sold it
so uh he actually got uh his first
american film role in a melodrama called
the silent command which came out in
1923
and he got off of the back of that i
kind of feel like he got a lot of other
uh
you know roles in silent films
mostly villains uh because of his look
uh you know or continental type roles
and these were all kind of like uh you
know productions that were made in and
around like the new york area so there
was that
now in 1927 over the summer
he got approached to star in a broadway
theater production a new adaptation of
dracula like i said the very famous
stage adaptation that had been adapted
from the book obviously
so
he agreed and he was in that and this
was wildly successful actually ran in
new york city for 261 performances and
then toured around the united states
and got a whole bunch of like you know
people came to see it it got all kind of
like really good reviews and stuff like
that throughout 1928 and 1929 so
he kind of made a name for himself
playing dracula on the stage like in
lots and lots of performances before he
even was in the movie
what i did was put it in the middle bowl
there's still two frozen put it in the
bowl put some water in it let it thaw a
little bit more maybe go down into 20
minutes
okay
you've got to make sure that center's
kind of thawed before you cook it people
the cooking time be all [ __ ] up yeah
okay
yeah juan said you bought the shirt for
tom for christmas yeah i thought it was
christmas i couldn't remember if it was
christmas or something
sure yeah
that's a good shirt i got you that one
and i got you um the conan one yeah that
said about like hearing the lamentations
yeah and stuff like that like on the
back
which is a good shirt but this thing is
too big a little bit i think it's a
medium i think it's a large
it's not though i always bought a medium
but the thing about it is that
there's something about it it didn't fit
different companies have different right
yeah
sizes it's still a good shirt so i'll
wear it yeah
it's like i just thought it was like
really funny
uh so yeah so he had been touring around
as dracula in this very very successful
stage production
now 1928
um the play like actually ended its west
coast run so he decides he's gonna stay
in california
but uh you know his performance on the
stage had actually kind of got some
interest from you know the larger film
industry so he got cast in a uh movie
called the veiled woman from 1929 that
was fox film
and he was in another movie called
prisoners which i think that came out
that same year um i don't i think that's
lost i don't think they have that
anymore which a lot of movies from the
silent era have been
um but that was actually released in a
silent movie version and a talky version
so 1929 uh he got a couple movies but
then after that like i kind of feel like
the film uh you know offers were drying
up
so then uh the dracula thing was doing
another like west coast tour so he's
like okay well i'll sign on for that so
he did that
now he also was in like some other like
later on he'd be in some other talkies
like i said he'd usually have to be like
uh a villain or he'd have to be like the
exotic chic type of character uh that
kind of stuff
so he at the around this time he started
to hear that oh they're making a film
version of the stage play of dracula
so he starts approaching the studio
saying hey obviously i've been playing
this role for however long the run was
which was very long and he's like so he
wanted to be in the movie
but universal pictures uh bella's gonna
see one their first choice really uh
they had a whole bunch of other actors
that were very prominent at the time
that were lined up uh so they started
making it in 1930. there was a bunch of
different actors uh john carradine was
one of them uh conrad white who'd been
in uh several silent films like man who
laughs and a couple of other ones uh
hands of warlock which actually i talked
about on my site but yeah so they wanted
uh one of them to play dracula but a
whole bunch of other ones were
considered
so
they actually cast another dude named
lou ayers he was actually uh
hired to play dracula at first but then
he got cast in a different like
universal movie so he had to like you
know
quit
so then they got another guy and then
they got this other guy named david
manners who was cast to play but then he
they moved him to harker and [ __ ] like
that
now because
bella lugosi had played the role on
broadway like i said the director who
came on todd browning was like okay fine
we'll put you in the movie
for the movie
bella lugosi was paid
3500
damn not much which i mean for the time
was probably okay but considering how
successful that film was and how it
spawned a whole entire [ __ ]
franchise of [ __ ] like that seems like
not really all that much and then all
the damn
look how many times it was played over
and over again royal season [ __ ] that's
what i mean yeah i mean it it i kind of
feel like it's the kind of thing where
three thousand dollars back down is
probably only like about a hundred
thousand today probably
which is yeah like i said it's not
nothing but it's not that much
considering the cultural impact that it
had i kind of feel like yeah right and
he probably didn't get any royalties
[Laughter]
but that's the thing you're a working
actor you don't really know
how successful this movie is going to be
that it's going to spawn this whole
[ __ ] cultural phenomenon and then
you're going to be like [ __ ] i wish that
i had said that i wanted
he wouldn't have got the
in
job
they probably would have because like i
said he wasn't not even on the list to
be honest even though he
played the role like many times you
would think he would be a no-brainer
because
his accent and where he was from wasn't
far from where
where where look where [ __ ] dracula
would have been
right which is velvia which had been
romania yeah yeah
so you would go yeah we'll use you and a
good thing that they did yeah
made it's an iconic character i mean
yeah
to think about it though and i kind of
feel like this was a problem that bella
lugosi struggled with the rest of his
life after this came out like i'm sure
he was probably like really excited
because he really wanted this role like
i said he loved playing that role he
played it on a stage many many times
and so when they were making the movie
he's like well obviously
um but
it i don't want to say it ended up
biting him in the ass but it kind of did
because he got so typecast he got so
like
locked into that one role
that nobody really saw him as much of
anything else like after that which is
kind of sad had he not taken that role
people would have saw him as nothing
though that's true that's what i mean
it's kind of like a double-edged sword
that's like really really never gotten
famous and like i said the same thing
like didn't happen to boris karloff i
guess because you know like i said he
was playing a monster so he wasn't
really playing somebody that looked like
himself necessarily like you'd still
tell it was him but it was like a lot of
makeup and he was a monster and stuff
but
you know lugosi that was all him
he wasn't
so a lot of it i think had to do with
karloff's name which was the stage name
that is a very memorable name
yeah you sound like a [ __ ] sorcerer
yeah or a magician
you know yeah he was kind of brilliant
coming up with that yeah
that might be part of it because if you
guys that's not his real name his real
name is william pratt yeah karloff
sounds like a dude that could disappear
call off the [ __ ] out of here
i'm gonna carl off the [ __ ] out of here
yeah yeah yeah step inside here comes
carla
yeah lugosi doesn't it sounds foreign
but it doesn't sound that awesome
i mean it is awesome but it's not quite
as it's not as awesome as carlos karloff
is a [ __ ] propaganda name
karloff i mean that sounds like it has
all those really hard consonants yeah
yeah
it sounds like you you're seeing
something you're serious about something
yeah like some dude from russia
that can [ __ ] disappear
in a cloud of smoke
you know what it sounds like
he could read minds
you know you can mesmerize women
[ __ ] like that that's what it sounds
like i know now i'm like picturing like
a [ __ ] poster
he's got a [ __ ] crystal ball touring
the continent yeah
he's got like a [ __ ] locker
[Laughter]
here he comes yeah yeah that's what like
i said i think it was the hard
consonants yeah all the hard concepts i
think that name
has something to do with it
yeah he does have the look to back it up
and he could act
but i think bella baylor lagos would
have been better to have a stage name
i mean that was a stage name but yeah
something that was like something that
sounds harder yeah
yeah
but like i said i don't even know if it
was yeah that might have factored into
it i think bella's main problem
was
his thick accent and honestly he didn't
really learn english until like later on
and i think that that might have limited
his roles in the beginning i'm gonna say
no
you know why
arnold schwarzenegger had a thick accent
they said he'd never make it in
hollywood he conquered hollywood
yeah but that's one case that doesn't
usually happen you can do it it can be
done but it doesn't really happen they
just have to be cast the right way
john rumble slap says bloody mcmurder
that should be a stage name yeah
could be could be that he didn't have
proper management they weren't casting
him the right way didn't have the right
representation in hollywood there's more
to it than that i mean his selfie
probably could have gone fur further
if he had somebody [ __ ] batten for
him with studios different kind of
producers that could back him for
[ __ ] projects that were good
they had a lot i think they had a lot to
do with it
because it's always a team effort it's
not so much
it's not so individual it wasn't it
wasn't bayla
well the thing like his son actually
said
he's like well he's like i know a lot of
people said oh maybe he had bad
management or something like that he's
like the thing about my dad was that he
just really liked to act and he would
just take whatever work
uh was offered yeah so
he's not building a legend for himself
and he's not
yeah but it kind of worked anyway
even though he didn't really live to see
it which is kind of sad
yeah
when he was alive he needed better
management probably he probably did yeah
i would imagine somebody said oh no
we're not going to have him in this
movie and we need to get this movie made
this movie if we get this movie made
when you got bayla in there it will
[ __ ] be a hit this movie's
this script is for him you know
but
[ __ ] like that really didn't come come
about until later you know what i mean
what the [ __ ] was that i don't know did
you see that too yeah
was that light or i don't know did one
of my lights flash and go out or some
[ __ ] like that i don't see anything
wrong back there yeah nothing's about it
it's just kind of flickered yeah
ghosts
you're haunting my [ __ ] again i think it
was
he was a little bit ahead of his time
and a dude like that appeared a little
bit later maybe you could have done more
with him
you know yeah
hey think about it you were limited in
his era of what kind of subjects you
could write his best movie is not
dracula
sorry people
if you ask me
his best movie is the black cat
which we reviewed not too long yeah and
that had boris karloff in it too right
and that's his best movie that's an
excellent movie [ __ ] love that movie
and that movie was pushing the
boundaries of what was possible
uh
it was a movie that had damn torture
stealing people's [ __ ] women stealing
their wives and their daughters
uh
necrophilia
[ __ ] guys human sacrifice satanism
they had all that in it
just a
that was his best movie per se i don't
think he that was
that didn't make him famous
but that was the best movie he was in
that's better than dracula
a lot of people think his best
performance actually came a little bit
later uh in like when he played uh igor
like the one with the broken neck or
whatever yeah what was that son of
frankenstein or something i didn't see
it i wish we'll get into that but i mean
i've always been a big fan of white
zombie to be honest but
i haven't i've seen it but i have to see
it again i mean he's been in like so
many movies like everybody knows about
dracula but holy crap he was in like so
many if you ask me overall when it came
to story and production and everything
that happens in the topic the best movie
he was in was black cat and both of
these guys were in it
and they were both excellent in it both
real good like i said we just reviewed
that not too long ago and that's
actually like yeah that's a really
really good movie that's a really good
movie i can't you know
when i was watching i said i couldn't
believe they actually did some of that
stuff in there yeah and i think that
movie actually made them
bring on the haze code
about what was it it might have been one
of the ones that was instrumental in
like that
coming in yeah because of like the stuff
they were it was like i said from now
from today's standpoint yeah it's all
like implication and hinting and
everything like that but i was like
amazed that they got away with some of
that crap back in the 30s holy crap yeah
i wouldn't have thought that they would
have done that what is that noise
thunder
i don't think it's thunder i think it's
somebody i think it's redness
it's right next to it it's called
redneck thunder
it's gonna be a drink i'm gonna [ __ ]
i'm gonna uh i gotta go out to the
[ __ ] boot uh that's right tomorrow
yeah because in case you guys weren't
here for the last friday we decided that
what we were gonna do because last
friday's show about taste testing colt
45 and colt 45 high gravity yeah was
like so fun and so successful i'm like
man every week we should go to the
liquor store and see what kind of
weird-ass [ __ ] that we can like taste as
i don't want to like
spend money on [ __ ] that i think is
going to be gross but i don't mind stuff
that would be like super cheap
you know that might be better than i
expect or something that's like
weird but might be awesome um you know
the series is going to be [ __ ] well
it's not going to be a regular series
but this little special series we're
going to do i'm going to be slumming
and try to find
low-cost stuff that is high value in
other words it's cheap but it's good
so far call 45 passed the test call 45
that was actually yeah that was actually
like way better than i was oh yeah for
what i paid 1.35 a can
i'd rather have that than budweiser
would i yeah it was pretty good so
very drinkable yeah and then i even
looked at the old ads back when back
before billy d back in the [ __ ] 60s
cole 45 spokesman was basically like a
james bond type dude
sitting sitting at a table at the beach
in his suit
looking talking about colt 45 it's all
serious like a secret agent a secret
agent is selling you a can of damn
[ __ ] malt liquor ain't this [ __ ] well
you know
that's how they did that [ __ ] back yeah
and then uh in the comment sections in
that one we have some people some dudes
from england saying oh yeah we got malt
like liquor here in england they're
[ __ ] naming off all the brands that
you try this brand and that brand but no
it's just
it's a cheap way of making [ __ ] a
beer-like product it tastes like beer
it's cheaper
it tastes like a high-quality cheap beer
so yeah high-quality bearded for less
all right so
like like i said let me let me get
through this [ __ ] go ahead dude let
me get through the topic okay all right
so um
okay
he just dropped his glasses on my foot
all right
so yeah so
i think what a lot of people forget is
that dracula and frankenstein came out
the same year now i think somebody
mentioned earlier
that lugosi
after the success of dracula was
actually offered the role of
frankenstein now
frankincense monster rather
um
there are conflicting stories about this
i think the most popular story is that
lugosi looked at the script and was like
i'm not doing that because one it he
doesn't have any lines and two
um i'll be underneath all this makeup
and nobody will recognize me so he
doesn't want to do it i don't know if
that's true or not but that's kind of
like the main story about it
um according to bella at least like in
his later years he actually didn't
really want to do it for whatever reason
but he recommended boris karloff i don't
know if that's true or not you know what
i mean because like i said i think they
wanted to sell the
rivalry between them later which
did have a little bit of basis in
reality but i think it was way overblown
because you know they could sell movie
tickets like later on they're like ooh
dracula versus frankenstein like these
two guys and they hate each other and
blah blah so i think they were doing
that just to sell movie tickets because
from everybody that knew them they were
like you know it wasn't really all that
bad
so what for whatever reason he turned
down the role of frankenstein's monster
and it ended up going to boris karloff
and of course you know that we all know
how that went
now as i mentioned because dracula was
such a success i mean obviously that's
good like for an actor but it also sort
of like ended up biting him in the ass
because he got absolutely typecast
everybody was just kind of like well
he's dracula and that's pretty much it
so when he would try out for other roles
they'll be like why is dracula here like
what you know what i mean so he would
get other roles but they would usually
be kind of like small roles and he'd
always have to be
like a villain or he would always kind
of have to have like you know and it
would just be [ __ ] like that it would be
like something that was similar to what
he had done before so he couldn't i feel
like he could never really like break
out of that
type you know the type casting that had
been kind of like thrust on him now he
did audition for some other roles like
he auditioned for rasputin
uh in the movie rasputin and the empress
which is 1932 but he lost it to lionel
barrymore
he also went out for another role in
charge of the light brigade from 1936
but was uh you know thrown over in favor
of c henry gordon and he also wanted to
be in this other movie uh tova rich from
1937 but lost the part to basil rathbone
even though bella lugosi had played the
exact same part in a stage production
of the same story
so yeah um like i said it's kind of sad
because he seemed like he had come up in
theater he had played a lot of diverse
roles once he did dracula like i said
that's great and everybody remembers him
because of that
but at the time when he was just trying
to like [ __ ] work and put food on the
table maybe not so good because
nobody would give him a chance like to
be anything other than that
so i guess he sort of accepted well i'm
just gonna be like the horror guy which
you know so that's kind of what he had
to do so he was in like a few other ones
obviously he was in murders of the brew
morgue which is the edgar allan poe
adaptation he was in a white zombie like
i said i actually really like white
zombie that was also from 1932. uh
island a lot of souls he was in that as
well marca the vampire from 1935 in
which he essentially played dracula
again but because of
uh
copyright issues they had to call him
something else but he looked pretty much
exactly the same
um so yeah and also like i said they
started kind of like pairing him with
boris karloff because you know the whole
monster mash thing that was like a big
thing at the time so the black cat which
was 1934 which like i said tom is really
into that movie and we reviewed it not
too long ago they also did uh the raven
in 1935 and like the invisible ray in
1936 so they did a bunch of movies
together and like i said the the studios
were kind of like hyping up this
rivalry between them which i think that
was kind of like overblown
now one thing that he was i think that
bella lugosi was probably understandably
like mad about
was that because karloff had i don't
know if he's necessarily been around for
longer but because he had
been
in more films like in more diverse roles
and because frankenstein was so iconic
even when like when karloff and lugosi
were in movies together
even if lugosi was technically playing
the lead role
boris karloff almost always got top
billing
and boris karloff in fact after
frankenstein was so famous
that he was one of those [ __ ]
that you could just like refer to him by
his last name like you didn't have to
put his first name on there it was just
karloff you know what i mean
and
so if a movie had boris karloff in it
and bella lugosi it'd be like karloff oh
and lugosi it's a big kind of like that
so i can see how if you were bella
lugosi yeah that would kind of like piss
you off a little bit but like i said i
from everything that i could determine
it doesn't seem like bella lugosi like
he didn't blame boris carlos for that
because like i said it wasn't boris
carlos fault it was whoever was making
the movies and whoever was making the
posters and all you know the production
companies behind it it wasn't boris
carlos fault that they did that but that
was something that he did seem to have
like a little bit of resentment about is
that even when he was the starring role
like karloff would get top billing
because he was like karloff so maybe
there is something to like what tom was
saying about like the name
that is kind of like and the thing about
we'll get into it we talk about boris
karloff a little bit more but boris
karloff i mean obviously like i said
that's not his real name his real name's
william pratt but um
he just kind of like essentially he
pulled that name out of his ass pretty
much um boris he just liked it because
it sounded foreign like it sounded
exotic and karloff he said oh it's from
my mom's side of the family is russian
or something like that but a lot of his
family members are like we don't know
what he's talking about that's like kind
of [ __ ] but he basically just like
made it up out of whole cloth but if he
did i mean it's a great name like i said
people still [ __ ] remember it and i
think it like i said it might have
contributed to why he was why his name
was a lot more memorable i guess
so uh there's that kind of thing and i
think that even at the time like karloff
was like well when we did movies
together
um
you know
lugosi with was thinking oh well this
englishman he's going to upstage me
but then when he
kind of got to know karloff and because
both of these dudes like by all accounts
were
super nice dudes and especially boris
karloff but he said he was just like the
nicest dude ever so
he wouldn't like
he doesn't seem like the type of dude
that would like go out of his way to be
like a [ __ ] to the dude or to somebody
else or anything like that like you know
and he seemed like he was just i don't
know everybody just said that he was a
really nice guy so he wouldn't have
really done that
so you know there's that kind of thing
but they seemed like to have a good
professional relationship even though
there was
some resentment maybe on lugosi's part
just because karloff was more successful
and like better known and blah blah
so now what ended up happening so uh so
lugosi is in some movies in the 30s and
like i said it's good but he's getting
typecast like i said he's not working as
regularly as he might like and a lot of
roles that he wanted that were in
non-horror movies he would usually lose
them to other actors now in august of
1938 though which is you know if you're
counting seven years after the original
uh dracula came out there was a
california theater owner named uh emil
uman i'm not sure if i'm pronouncing
that right who got it in his head he's
like oh i know what i'm going to do i'm
going to revive
the um you know the universal monster
the dracula and frankenstein movies and
i'm going to do like a double feature
like i'm going to show him my theater
and i'm going to do dracula versus
frankenstein it'll be this big thing
and that ended up being like way more
successful than anybody had ever
anticipated like and like i said it's
only been seven years so
it seems like not that long a time but
you know a lot of movies had come out
and everybody just kind of like moved on
from it but he's like yeah i'm going to
bring him back and i'm going to make it
like a monster match kind of thing
so it was like hugely hugely successful
and the fact that it was so successful i
mean he had to add on like extra
showings and all this other kind of
stuff because people just like line up
around the block like to see them and it
was such a big deal that he actually
like called up bella lugosi and said hey
like do you want to come here in person
like in your cape and everything like
that people would love that so
you know so he would like come out and
do that and like be at the theater show
and everybody [ __ ] loved that [ __ ]
and it almost kind of like reinvigorated
his career a little bit because you're
getting i know it was only seven years
but you're getting like a new generation
of kids that hadn't seen the original
films and now they're seeing them and
they really dug them so
there was uh it was kind of like gave
him like a little bit shot in the arm
so after that happened i guess the
studio
was kind of like oh maybe there's still
some mileage left in old bella lugosi
even though i'm old like i said
the thing about it both lugosi and
karloff were a little bit older when
they started out like i said karloff was
it was i think it was 43 when he played
frankenstein's monster i can't remember
how old lugosi was when he played
dracula but he wasn't young so
it's not kind of like a thing where
they cam came out and like they were big
stars like they in their 20s and stuff
and then they kind of aged out they were
older when they started so
you know the fact that they were in like
a few movies and they got like super
famous and then they kind of started
getting older and like you know so it
was kind of a thing but they like i said
they were older when they started so
it's kind of like a different
situation so the studio is like all
right well maybe there is some life left
in bella lugosi so they uh kind of hired
him to act in some more movies
so um
well actually one of his later roles
that a lot of people point to is
probably being his best one
uh was as i mentioned earlier son of
frankenstein where he plays igor that
was 1939
um where he had like he had been like
hanged i guess and his neck was broken
but he survived so he has like this
[ __ ] bone sticking out of his neck so
he was like great in that um he was also
he played igor again in ghost of
frankenstein which is 1942 but by that
time like i said yeah he had like a
little resurgence like in the late 1930s
but it didn't last very long sadly so
they kind of put him in a few more
movies and then he just from that point
on i think 1942 not right around there
or i think evan costello meet
frankenstein was like the last time that
he was like in a big budget like a-list
kind of picture
after that he kind of started working on
poverty row kind of movies and you know
exploitation flicks stuff like that
now uh as we brought up earlier
um because he had been
injured when he was in the military
that's what the story is i don't know if
that's true or not
um but apparently he had real bad uh
sciatica i think it was
now
at first he was kind of like just taking
some just regular ass pain remedies or
whatever that weren't you know uh
addiction inducing i guess
but the doctor started
giving him uh opioids you know so
he got addicted to morphine over these
time periods because like i said because
of injuries and things like that it's a
painkiller addiction
now uh and then after that in 1947 like
later on 1947 when methadone became
available in the united states um he got
addicted to that as well like as doctors
prescribed it and he like i said he just
maintained that addiction over all that
time period
so um that's the thing uh
you know his last big movie being the
abbott costello one which is actually
like a good movie it's a good comedy and
everything like that but by that point
like i said by the 1940s
everyone was kind of like they thought
that the universal monsters were like
they weren't scary anymore they were
just like funny so they were all in
comedy so he was in that and then after
that he just went and shitty and like i
said he
uh you know because of his drug
addiction and because there was he also
had some problems with alcoholism as
well during this time period
so
he was not in the best shape um and he
kind of got a little bit of a reputation
about like being i don't think he was
necessarily difficult to work with but
you know anybody that's like an addict
or a drunk or anything like that like
you know they're probably not going to
be at their peak performance so there's
that kind of thing
so uh the thing is too about what i
wanted to mention about abbott
castellami frankenstein was that
in the original
uh take of the film like when he was in
it because he plays frankenstein's
monster in that which is kind of ironic
because he apparently turned down the
role of frankenstein's monster in the
very iconic like james whale movie that
you know boris karloff got famous for so
he's playing frankenstein's monster in
abbott castleman frankenstein
and he initially had lines in the movie
but for whatever reason when they cut it
for theater release they cut all of his
dialogue out
so
his monster in the movie like looks it
doesn't he doesn't say anything and he
just kind of like looks like he's
lumbering around with his arms out and
almost kind of looks like a parody even
though originally he did have lines but
they cut all of that out and he was like
really really pissed off that they did
that
especially that being like the last big
film that he was in
so there was that
now he was in a couple other good movies
after this like he was in the body
snatcher in 1945 which was also with
boris karloff in which they played like
you know body snatchers obviously it was
kind of loosely based on broken hair i
think so they both actually like played
people on that and that was actually
pretty good
and so there was that
now
the thing about it so
after this point he just really started
not getting work like i said because the
studios were kind of done with them like
he was having problems with drug
addiction
and then famously he meets up with ed
wood who
i saw this one documentary earlier that
said this said this in a very diplomatic
way it said well he had more ambition
than talent and i said well that's a
nice way of putting it
a poor ed wood he seemed to mean well he
really did
but he didn't have jack [ __ ] idea how to
make a [ __ ] movie uh so there's that
but he was a big fan of bella lugosi and
he knew that bella lugosi was having
some problems
so he basically is like well bella
lugosi is like the biggest name actor
that i'm gonna get my hands on
so i'm gonna call him up and see
if i can have him be in some of my like
[ __ ] z grade pictures
so uh so ed wood much as they portray in
the movie like i said the tim burton
movie from 1994 is excellent
but it is uh exaggerated you know it's
it's a little bit fictionalized
but apparently edward did actually find
uh bella lugosi living in poverty
and uh was a big fan of his so it's like
hey you need to be in my movies
so the first movie of ed woods that he
was in was infamously glenn or glenda
from 1953.
movie about transgenderism
yeah which is cross-dressing yeah it's
more it's transvestism it's not really
transgender because yeah because ed wood
was straight but he was a cross-dresser
and he just wanted to which is crazy
watching it nowadays because i'm like in
a way it's like it's a terrible movie
but it's like it's kind of way ahead of
its time which one the glenda glass
glenda yeah it's an awful movie though
but it's it's like a fake documentary
it's fun to watch it's fun to watch ed
wood had some i mean
there's wood he's iconic for a reason i
mean he had some weird ass ideas about
like what would make a good movie ed
wood
was a marine all right he fought the
[ __ ] he fought the [ __ ] battle of
peleliu on the island of pelham one of
the [ __ ] most savage
wars of most savage battles of all
[ __ ] times they were [ __ ] cutting
people's heads off [ __ ] had japanese
heads they were torturing people [ __ ]
setting japanese dudes on fire
he went through the whole [ __ ] battle
of pele
with women's [ __ ] underwear on
underneath his second uniform and he
wasn't scared of getting killed he was
afraid of getting wounded
because they would find out because
they'd find out he's wearing that [ __ ]
see people are complicated yeah
you can't just be like oh it's like oh
well they can't be a badass because they
have women's panties on
he had he's uh he had these issues
he wanted to be calmed by the feeling of
[ __ ] having women's clothing on him
and feeling
having women's clothing on him reminded
him of [ __ ] i guess his mom and uh
would would reduce
stress on him and he felt comforted by
it
so he didn't have to be a man i guess i
don't [ __ ] know what it was
but he was open about it around his
friends he'd [ __ ] put his [ __ ]
[ __ ] he put his women's
clothes on in front of his friends they
have a party and [ __ ] but
when he was in the marines he had to
[ __ ] hide this
[ __ ] funny
it is
he seemed like he was troubled uh like a
lot of people back then were but you
know what i mean yeah and he was
straight he was looking into women he
liked women he was not gay you just
like to [ __ ] that's what i mean people
are complicated you can't just like it's
you know it's a spectrum that's what
they say yeah just like black and white
but yeah so uh so yeah so edward gave
him a role in glenda glenda where he was
mostly he was mostly like kind of like a
puppet master type character in that uh
he was also in bride of the monster uh
from 1955
um you know so there was that and
honestly
one of my favorite scenes in ed wood
like the movie
was when they steal the octopus
from the studio lot to put in the at the
end of their movie
the end of the bride of the monster
and they forgot to steal the octopus
motor so then they make poor old bella
lugosi who was like an old drug addicted
guy at this time
and they're just like made poorly bella
like laying out this cold water at night
and they're just like move his legs
around make it look like it's killing
you
and that's kind of as far as i know
that's pretty similar to what actually
did happen but i mean i mean bella was a
trooper
uh you know he he loved theater he loved
acting and stuff like that and he was
game i mean he probably wasn't feeling
too good but he's just like he would do
whatever if to be in a movie even if it
was terrible he wanted to get that
morphine
probably yeah i mean there was that too
yeah
but
yeah so he was in i mean and the thing
about it is that he has actually
even though those are terrible movies i
mean they're still entertaining they're
terrible but they're entertaining but he
has like some great [ __ ] monologues
like that [ __ ] monologue that he has
at the end where he's just like yeah
it's like a bride of the monster or
whatever we just like hunted despised
[Laughter]
so good that [ __ ] edward wrote which is
he poorly written by ed wood delivered
like i mean it doesn't i mean this [ __ ]
that edward wrote it absolutely makes no
sense it makes absolutely nothing like
ghosts he was taking this seriously he
did and it's like he gave he gave that
[ __ ] some conviction son like i said you
gotta like [ __ ] respect that
he didn't phone the [ __ ] in no
he treated it completely seriously and
i'm like like i said you gotta [ __ ]
respect that because the script was
terrible but that wasn't that wasn't his
fault
ed would like i said well i think that's
why everybody remembers ed wood movies
nowadays just because the scripts are so
[ __ ] bizarre like the stuff that
people say in there i'm just kind of
like alrighty nobody talks like that
they would show them
channel 13 [ __ ] out in l.a when i was
a little boy
and uh
for the monster [ __ ] monster [ __ ]
afternoon you know monster matinee
and we kind of liked him we liked him we
didn't know any better yeah and i guess
ed knew that we didn't know any better
that we were the more target market
yeah
it's like hey we knocked over the
cardboard gravestones it's like no one's
gonna notice yeah
i don't remember it torah johnson ran
into a wall like ran into a cardboard
wall and like the whole [ __ ] set
shook you know what i mean it's that
kind of stuff yeah so you know
uh but yeah
so now while they were working on bride
of the monster like after it had already
been shot and they were doing like the
post-production on it which is hard to
believe that there was any
post-production on pride of the monster
but okay i've seen it like multiple
times it's on mst if you want to watch
it with uh you know with riffing on it
now dir while they were doing
post-production on pride of the monster
bella lugosi as we mentioned earlier uh
went to a treatment center for drug
addiction
and when they did the premiere of the
film they actually used the money that
they raised from the premier of the film
to pay for some of his hospital expenses
that was kind of a nice touch
so uh
so there was that
and as we mentioned earlier he's
actually like the first hollywood star
to come out and say yeah i went to rehab
like i'm a drug addict
so they did an interview with him after
he got out from the treatment center in
1955 like i said he was in for three
months and i saw some footage of him
coming out
uh and he looked actually in good shape
like i said he's an old man he's an old
man he was 74.
but
he came out like he bound it out and
he's like hey everybody and stuff and
all the media was there and everything
like that so he looked like he had
gotten his [ __ ] together i was like yeah
i'm cured and all this other kind of
stuff
um now while he was uh being interviewed
he said yeah i'm working on another ed
wood movie called the ghoul goes west
which i think they bring up in the
in the edward movie like the tim burton
one so this was uh like edward he had
like a whole slate of pictures
uh planned whether he'd actually written
them or done anything about it he just
had like the titles and the ideas and
stuff
dr
acula
[Applause]
[Laughter]
and he's like oh i don't like it but
yeah so see edward it's like it's an
awesome movie but yeah so uh so he said
he was gonna be working on that
so
while he was
thinking about the next movie he was
gonna make he didn't really have a
particular script in mind
so he starts filming bella lugosi in his
dracula cape
in front of various locations he shot
him in front of tor johnson's house uh
he shot him in front of like a graveyard
like in some suburbs somewhere and in
front of uh bella's apartment building
that he was living in so the little
house was torah's house uh i think that
was torah's house yeah because bella was
living in the la house yeah cause bella
was living in an apartment complex at
that time like there is some footage of
him like from in front of that uh that
apartment complex to you but so yeah so
they filmed all this kind of stuff and
then uh so he films all that and he's
like yeah i'm gonna put that like in an
upcoming movie
um but what happened was that in 1956
bella lugosi died in his sleep
so i mean thankfully he died to sleep
he's like
no he didn't like his wife uh his fifth
wife at the time hope she who was
actually like a fan of his okay and had
been writing to him for several years
because his fourth wife really is she
um she was quite a bit younger yeah
quite a bit younger
um she might have been younger than that
i can't really remember i think there
was like a 20 or 30 age different 20 or
30 year age difference but um she yeah
she had been a fan of his and like wrote
to him and stuff but i don't think she
was married to him for that long like
before he died like his fourth wife
prior to that was lillian who is
uh you know bella jr like because you
see him like on a lot of dive if you see
a documentary about bella lugosi like
his son will be on there um bella jr is
on there and that's lillian is his mom
but that was bella's fourth wife i think
so uh hope was his fifth wife she found
him dead like in his bed he died in his
sleep
peacefully it was just a heart attack
so because he died in 1956 uh ed wood
decided well i'm going to use this
footage
and i'm going to put it in plan 9 from
outer space which came out in 1957
and uh most famously i think everybody
knows this at this point because he
wanted to put
bellagosi's character like the dracula
character in there this movie makes no
[ __ ] sense so he's like well i'm
gonna hire this guy he's my wife's
chiropractor his name was tom mason i
thought he was a dentist no he was a
chiropractor and he's like and i'm going
to put him in there as a stand-in for
bellagos and he's just going to keep the
cape over his face even though the dude
was like way taller and bigger
than bella lugosi was
um and it's obviously not the same dude
but you know
i mean
the thing about all that i saw that
movie when i was a kid and i didn't
notice anything yeah i didn't notice
anything about it well you wouldn't if
you're with us when you're
and that was that's what they were doing
that's what that's who they were making
those for oh the kids are going to love
it you know it
that's what they were doing
that's like really funny
it was funny
funny when you think about it when you
when you think about out in front of
johnson's house looking at old l.a i was
born there okay i left and thank you
bryce thank you what do you say loving
the diverse content well thank you very
much thank you i was born there [ __ ]
left in 81. [ __ ]
where they're showing is the ghetto now
all right it wasn't the ghetto back then
uh but you know most of the united
states back in that era didn't have like
extensive subur suburban areas
didn't have any of that
california was way ahead back in those
days now that [ __ ] is everywhere
and uh the areas that they're talking
about are just worn out kiddos now but
it's just [ __ ] funny to think about
it how small
american cities were at that time and
kind of how new the modern city was
yeah because the the suburb was a
post-world war ii invention really
yeah in fact most people lived in either
in the city or in shacks
out in the middle of the country there
wasn't anything in between yeah but it's
just funny to see [ __ ] bellagosa
baylor out there in that old [ __ ]
footage it's like old trafford housing
and he's in front of track house and it
looks like something straight out of
down it looks like straight out of
edward scissorhands
smaller i know those houses uh
i wasn't born in one but i kind of
partially grew up to one it's i can give
you the address you guys can even google
it and look at it
it's 2524
jackson street
carson california right outside [ __ ]
dominguez elementary the same elementary
school that [ __ ]
well what's his name went to quentin
quentin tarantino went to that
elementary school he was a couple years
older than me
i vaguely remember him and then he
worked at the dam
he worked at the [ __ ]
uh worked at the damn video rental store
down over there where the where el
ranchito's mexican [ __ ] restaurant
used to be
yeah i remember the whole area dominguez
but yeah so what i was going to say was
that when
as awesome as the tim burton ed wood
movie is
as i said um relatives of
both bela lugosi and boris karloff they
said that as as awesome as martin
landau's performance as bella goes and
he got an oscar for that [ __ ] and
rightfully so because he was amazing i
actually forgot that was an actor then
that bellagosi was actually like not
alive anymore yeah
um
but they said that one bella lugosi
would never have said because he's it's
hilarious it's a hilary scene like in
the movie where he says boris carl croft
is not fit to smell my [ __ ] he says but
he's like he he would have never have
said that um it's like actually he
really he quite liked boris karl after
they had like a professionally like
respectful relationship and he never
would have said he he didn't really use
swear words like that and they said and
also you know there's a scene in there
where a vampire and he's like says
something like she has nice jugs or
something it's like yeah he never would
have said anything like that
like he didn't well they're just saying
that he didn't talk like that yeah yeah
you know what i mean he was in dirty
mouth yeah they said that honestly and
his son said that he had like a lot of
really good memories of his dad like his
dad like always spent a lot of time with
him and was like really involved in
family life and stuff and everybody
seemed like he was said that he was like
a really nice dude yeah you know so
there was that like i said he was
married several times and when he was
younger uh as i mentioned he uh had a
reputation a little bit of a ladies man
and was seen with some kind of like hot
starlets at the time clara beau uh you
know he supposedly had an affair with
her among others but and he was married
five times but you know he definitely
would have liked mela though he'd have
been coming yeah yeah yeah and the whole
her whole vampira outfit and [ __ ] like
that even if he would like that how do
you do that yeah yeah
she understands you know
you know [ __ ] baylor invented that
look basically he did it the male
version of it
october says october it said check out
the movie with jeff goldblum mr frost i
actually really really like that movie
and i feel like hardly i'm you and me
are like the only people that remember
that one i feel like now the thing about
that um so lugosi bella lugosi was
buried as dracula cape most famously
uh contrary to popular belief
i don't think he ever actually said that
he wanted that
um according to his son
and uh his son's mom who was you know
bellagosi's fourth wife
they just did that because they thought
that that was what he would have wanted
because he did love that role but i
don't think he ever specifically
requested hey barryman but because they
said we're
i don't think it was just the cape it
was the cape and the ring and the whole
outfit yeah they just stopped
yeah that's what they thought well they
knew him and they're like that's he
would have liked that so that's what
we're gonna do like i don't think he
ever specifically requested but
because like i said he the thing about
bella was that
um
you know when he got out of rehab he
really thought you know even though he
was 74 he's like hey i'm making a
comeback or whatever so he always had
like a really optimistic
attitude about the future like hey i'm
gonna like go on to greater things even
though he was old you know what i mean
which i don't know i guess that's kind
of like a cool attitude to have so i
made more ed wood movies he probably
would have yeah
yeah
which they were i mean ed wood would
have kept well and the thing about it
like say what you will about ed wood
they were bad but they weren't they made
money they did people i mean people were
like
well i kind of feel like
i don't know if they made any money at
the time
but
i think hindsight has been kind to them
i mean people remember ed wood nowadays
because he was so terrible so there is
also there's like a talent in that
it was it was you have to you have to
consider the times
television wasn't as well developed as
it had be ended up being become later on
what edward was doing was really low
budget
matinee cinema
for young boys
of that era
it was the tv of its time a little bit
better than tv maybe
people try to get rid of their kids man
gonna grow the matinee [ __ ] was [ __ ]
get out of here get out of here
and that's what they were doing go watch
a bunch of movies yeah go watch smiles
out of my head
yeah that's what they're doing so you
know
ed was able to continue producing for a
while
the industry overtook him though better
movies started to [ __ ] appear
tv got better
uh the game started to become more
elevated
but he there was probably another couple
movies
out of edward though if bella was with
him because i think [ __ ] bella
actually carried ed wood for a little
bit
and movies would have never been
remembered if bella was if bella wasn't
in the end
and i mean yeah because bella lugosi was
easily the yeah you got torah johnson
but it's like tor johnson was a wrestler
so he wasn't as big a name as bella you
couldn't really do that much of a
speaking part and [ __ ] you had bella
and [ __ ] bella would get kids to see
the movies
you know
and you remember them because they were
recorded and saved
yeah because they pulled the string
they were remembered and recorded
because bella was in them
bill it wasn't in those
they'd be long forgotten
that's true so although like i said
there is something very entertaining
about their very terribleness yeah
more than because
one thing you can say about ed wood
movies is that they weren't boring like
a lot of 50s like
like real cheap low budget 50s movies
were just boring it was just like a
bunch but ed wood movies were not
because they were so
bizarre like all the choices that he
made yeah uh were just so weird that
it's like you couldn't help but be
entertained yeah
and it was mostly um
white dudes in
well no they had white girls too but a
lot of it was white dudes in offices
talking to each other on the phone about
what's gonna happen
uh people in fake cockpits uh
white chicks coming in to [ __ ] with a
clipboard to [ __ ] say some [ __ ] uh
and then bella lugosi doing experiments
it was you know it was it was it was
stuff like that
out in the graveyard but it's obviously
fake there's just all kinds of [ __ ] yeah
all the cards that didn't get into it
but there was probably a couple more
movies out of the
ed wood bella lugosi the ghoul goes west
yeah that movie would have probably
happened and it probably would have done
just like the other ones you know what i
mean that one sounds like the worst of
them all so we're probably like really
entertaining there's no talent because
ed's writing didn't get better
[Laughter]
well he also had some alcoholism
problems
admittedly yeah ed wouldn't [ __ ]
wouldn't use anybody else's scripts and
that's a problem okay but there wasn't
anybody writing for ed okay
these were just
pull it out of your ass [ __ ] zero
budget movies but they were movies and
they kept they kept old bella [ __ ]
active all right
and he eventually once bella was dead
that was the end of ed wood he ended up
making
i think i think he did like porn now
yeah he did really bad titty movies they
weren't even really porn they were just
like soft car barn titty movies girls
dancing with titties strippers
and
they're forgotten
so
no edward was remembered because of
bella lugosi yeah
and bella goes he [ __ ] acted in those
movies he did like i said he took it
very seriously yeah yeah yeah he didn't
phone that [ __ ] in yeah and like i said
i will always respect that yeah bayless
carey and those
bella carried those whole [ __ ] movies
on the foot on his back and they were
they were movies for kids basically they
were not intended for an adult audience
not who the per that's not
that's not who was paying the [ __ ]
that's not the asses in those seats the
asses in those seats were kids
yeah and that was mostly what it was
with science fiction and horror in that
era they didn't have adult fans really
that wasn't until later you were looking
you know what i mean psycho kind of uh
that really did kind of change that
because prior to that i kind of feel
like horror and sci-fi that was more
like you said seen as like a kids genre
they didn't really take it all that
seriously
so it's like we're not gonna like make
it right good like we're not gonna give
any quality too it's just like a bunch
of dumb kids watching it so yeah so just
as quick as possible as cheap as
possible
kind of like a [ __ ] chinese wushu
kung fu flick
similar they just were made quickly
um
shot and edited in camera uh the guys
that were making [ __ ] chinese wushu
they'd be they're filming five movies at
the same time five different movies at
the same time with the same cast yeah
and the dude's trying to keep all the
shits well yeah they're trying to like
economize right yeah
that's basically what edward was but
nowhere near the budget yeah i don't
even think he had enough he had the same
amount of money as they had no he had to
steal [ __ ] to get it in the movie sure
all right so let's talk about boris
karloff
now that we're
two hours and 30 minutes in
i'm going to check the chicken all right
he's gonna go check the chicken out
and uh yeah christopher bell said belle
and boris were never enemies yeah i
really wanted to
they really kind of like sold like
i don't know i kind of feel like they
really played that up
um
because yeah like it's funny and it's
rivalry and conflict and that always
sells and stuff but
according to everybody that knew them
and according to everybody that was
around at the time their relatives and
stuff like that said yeah they didn't uh
hate each other at all they had like a
good they weren't friends i don't think
but they had a good professional
relationship and a lot of like mutual
respect for one another all the stuff
that came out later about
you know like i said it's funny in tim
burton's movie but
that's not bella lugosi didn't like feel
that way about boris karloff like i said
he might have been a little bit
professionally resentful that he wasn't
as successful maybe but like i said he
never i don't as far as i know he never
blamed boris karloff himself for that so
he wasn't like resentful towards garlic
himself
all right so boris karloff obviously not
his real name uh born william henry
pratt in 1887 which is crazy it's a long
time ago uh in a place called camberwell
london england now he was actually the
youngest of nine children
now i think either both his parents died
when he was young or his dad took off
and his mom died but he didn't grow up
with like both of his parents like he
was actually pretty young when they were
when he didn't have parents anymore
so he actually got raised mostly by his
older siblings like he had a half sister
and he had like some older brothers and
stuff so they were the ones that raised
him because his parents smells so good
down there man it smells good up here i
had to turn it way down to 200. we'll
just slow cook it now that's seared on
the outside so we'll just what you're
going to make with it again you're just
baking make some mint i got rice made or
i can make mashed potatoes i think
mashed potatoes okay
i'm kind of over rice we've helped out a
lot because we've had a lot of indians
got i have this um i thought some um
hamburger i'll make some and i got that
rice so i got old rice
i'll make some meatloaf
with rice in it and it's like uh
some green peppers from the garden and
everything like meatloaf for tomorrow
for tomorrow yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's good yeah so i was gonna like
you're doing baked chicken right
no no i'm also prepping for what
tomorrow yeah planning ahead that's what
i thought constantly planning
so so yeah so boris was actually uh
because he didn't have parents uh as
younger he was actually like raised by
his half-sister and his older siblings
now a lot of his family including all of
his brothers were in diplomatic service
so they were kind of like high up in the
government or whatever
so his dad as we mentioned earlier was
uh half i believe a half anglo half
indian
and uh because his yeah his dad had a
british dad and an indian mother okay
and then karloff's mother was also i
don't think she was half indian but she
did have some indian ancestry
so when boris karloff was a kid like if
you see pictures of him as a kid like
you can look online and i've seen him in
documentaries and stuff he was um fairly
dark-skinned like for the time
and so he did we there's a great
documentary on shutter if you have
shutter that's called the man behind the
monster where they kind of go into this
a little bit but he got picked on a lot
because he wasn't uh
lily white is the other kid so he's
western european probably around one
quarter indian from india not american
indian yeah
okay yeah
so you never know
you wouldn't really but when they kind
of you have to [ __ ] put him in when
they put him like would have put a beard
on him or like somebody he does look
more once they mentioned it and i'm
looking at him in in in color i would go
yeah i kind of see it but you know what
he looks almost arabic like something
like omar sharif or something yeah do
you remember my old martial reef yeah i
remember i think i'm not even sure he
was [ __ ] arabic but it probably was
at least his name was that's the thing
back then it's like a lot of
you never could tell because it's like
they had like a bunch of italians
playing native americans yeah all that
kind of thing his name is omar sharif
and you check and he goes oh man no he's
jewish you know what i mean they can
just do it anything
they name you took a stage name based
upon the image you wanted and what yeah
and what you look like and what kind of
roles you were expected to get right and
you'd have these uh a lot of these
hotties old silver screen hottie females
they'd have these exotic french sounding
names they're from southern california
they're chicana women you know part of
mexico that happened a lot actually well
didn't like rita hayworth i think she
was uh
she was latina i think yeah yeah and
they yes
yeah and they and they uh dyed her hair
red and like changed her name and
everything like that because they didn't
want they wanted her to be like yeah
yeah yeah all this [ __ ] today they
think diversity is new no diversity in
the united and yeah but back then it was
100 years it wasn't as but it wasn't
acknowledged as diversity though it's
like we're trying to make everybody like
not on tv that's what i'm saying tv
was for the general of american audience
american tv was and then movies were
designed for a general american audience
and they were literally g-rated a lot of
that [ __ ] and everything was made
generic
and everything was made and the generic
the generic [ __ ] american
ethnic group was just white
you know western european that's who
they were marketing to that's where the
money was but when you really looked
looked at the [ __ ] people involved in
this this goes back
to all of hollywood and television
it's basically white and hispanic with a
few blacks that's really what it was
and uh if you go back and you also look
at the actual numbers
the the racial makeup of northern
america has been pretty similar about 13
black
about you know 50 something or 60
um what you would call kind of caucasian
and then the rest of them would be some
kind of like
what you would call like latino today
which is funny because a lot of latinos
are caucasian depending on where they
come from it's a it's ridiculous you
know
ridiculous divisions um amongst the
ethnic groups in north america
so
jenny's back okay sorry i had to figure
well like i said it's like you know yeah
in
in practice well i don't even know if i
want to say that but it's like yeah
actually there was diversity but you
weren't allowed to say that it was
diversity because they were always
trying to like put trying to make it
look they were trying to like make it
look white and generic or trying to like
fit you if you looked a little bit not
white and generic then they'd be like
okay well you're an asian it's like yeah
but i'm from puerto rico you know what i
mean it was like that kind of [ __ ] yeah
they were trying to make it yeah but you
look not white yeah you gotta be not
from nearby but on the other side of the
goddamn planet you're real super exotic
it was like the carnival
the more exotic you were the [ __ ]
better if you were chicana or [ __ ]
which is a mixture of
basically irish americans and and well
victor says chicano is american born of
mexicans yeah yeah it's american border
mexican descent but i grew up in that
area and i [ __ ] my friends that were
going to dominguez high school [ __ ]
more than half of them were chicano and
the girls were chicana of course
yeah they were mexican-american but they
were also
heavily racially integrated with [ __ ]
irish americans and german americans
they were tart
caucasian at least half
jeffy art says omar sharif was egyptian
i think it was egyptian oh i'd have to
look that up right really sure and a lot
of the a lot of the chicano
or or chicano
people that i grew up with in in high
school a lot of them aren't there
anymore they moved away
they moved away
out of california they would move deeper
into the united states and they married
white people or mexican people just
depend
it's just just like the native american
indians you know ever everybody was
interbreeding with each other
and like when i was in the army all the
guys that i knew that were from the
islands
like hawaii and hawaiian and pacific
island guys that [ __ ] i served with
they're all here on in the mainland they
didn't go back home they're all married
to white girls
and it has been going on for [ __ ]
centuries
if you make it you end up in the [ __ ]
mainland of the united states you end up
marrying who you work with that's all it
is
yeah so
it's harder to see like when he's you
know older like when he's at i guess
like when you see like younger picture
but if you see pictures of him as a kid
yeah he was kind of like at least
compared to you know the super white
like uh other english kids he kind of
got picked on some because he was kind
of uh dark looking now he was actually
uh spent his school years in enfield
you know which you know we've talked
about that anfield poltergeist yes
so yeah uh he went to enfield grammar
school and then later went to some
private schools yeah what's funny is
that if you're a north american
when you see karloff his acting work you
assume he's just some british blue blood
you know i mean [ __ ] that's how he
pulled himself off
you know what i mean you would never
know that he was a brit of mixed
background but the thing about it though
was that his family because i mean his
family were all consular yeah because
they
and we'll kind of get into this because
i kind of feel like everybody in his
family like his brothers and everything
like that were in the consulates they
were all like high up in government
service and like i said at this time you
know it was very the you know the very
colonial like english thing with over
india and everything so a lot of them
were high up in government positions and
i kind of think that they expected him
to do the same thing now when he went
into acting
i don't know necessarily if his family
because bella lugosi his family were
just kind of like yeah no that's not a
thing that we're doing we we want like
some actual like trades that you've
learned
boris karloff i think he had that
perception that his family felt that
like they expected him to go into
government service just like they did
and then when he was went into acting
i think he kind of perceived himself as
maybe a little bit of a black sheep
but
after he got
successful um and he went back to see
his family they were actually like all
into it now i don't know if it was just
because he got famous so it might be
that like if he was just a struggling
actor they might not have like responded
to him in the same way
but he i don't know why but he always
like perceived that his family like
thought maybe he was the black sheep
because he didn't go into consular
service like the rest of them did and
was like an actor so i kind of feel like
he maybe had a little bit of
i don't know he had some feelings about
that but i don't know how like accurate
they were because i don't know his
family but so uh so yeah so he actually
did go to university with you know at
first like in the early 1900s with a
view to going along the same lines as
his family was but he really wasn't
having it and he dropped out
and then he just kind of like wandered
around like he left england and he
actually went to canada and much like
bella lugosi like he kind of worked his
way across he basically worked on farms
uh and just did odd manual labor like
trying to work his way across the
country like canada in his case uh
united states and bela lugosi's case but
same kind of like uh they ended up in
pretty much the same place now the thing
about uh boris karloff was that not only
uh was he
mixed race uh he was also when he was
younger bow-legged
and he had a lisp which actually he
still had like for all of his life
but you could kind of hear it in the
movies you can hear it and that's the
thing but
it's like it made it he made it work for
him yeah like i kind of feel like he did
try to get rid of it
but he never could
and i guess in the end maybe he was just
like [ __ ] it i'm just gonna like you
know lean into it it was a classy list
and it was yeah and so
you know and i kind of feel like it
almost kind of like worked in his favor
which is weird that's kind of like a
good
that's a good like example of like using
a weakness quote-unquote and making it
something that's like distinctive to you
because that's like his voice is one of
the most iconic things about him even
though he obviously did have a list
there's a scene where he's talking to
[ __ ] uh
[ __ ] lugosi in black cat over the
damn
chessboard and he's this satanic like
sith lord inside his castle
futuristic [ __ ] was futuristic back
then but it even looked
it was very nice very art deco looking
tower of glass and steel and [ __ ] and
he's moving the chess pieces around
[ __ ] and they're playing for the fate
of this young american couple with the
hot check and [ __ ] and [ __ ] he's
going to try to steal the hot check
venus is going to try to save her
and he's talking to venus and he's
obviously lisping
in that but it sounds cool
he's playing that's the way that he
plays it off i mean normally i can't
yeah he's obviously listening i i
recognized that even back in the day
yeah but it's just he has a really cool
accent and the way he delivers it it
sounds like real stylish
that's what i mean that's kind of like a
prime example of
something that in most people yeah that
would be like something that you would
need to overcome because it was like an
imperfection but for whatever reason
it worked for him yeah i think that he
like i said i think he did try to not
have it like he did have um you know he
was bow-legged and he did kind of like
work his way through that
but he never could get rid of that lisp
and i think after a while he was just
like i'm just gonna
have it and that became like a signature
and like i said his voice is probably
one of his most iconic things he [ __ ] he
would do voiceovers later on in his
career yeah and that was kind of one of
the things he was most famous for was
that voice so
it wasn't a detriment in the end i think
that's like a really good example of
like using something that would normally
be seen as a weakness and in
in anyone else's case it might have been
but the fact that he just owned it
and it just became a thing that he had
and it worked for him i don't think it
would work for everybody it just depends
but it worked for him so it was the
delivery
yeah i think i mean the fact that slow
and measured delivery yes facial
expressions and yeah that that's how he
got like i said it's just it made him
very distinctive because like i said it
was just he had that great face
and that great like which was kind of
craggy and he was kind of like weird and
then he had a statue yeah and then he
had like that voice that had like a
little bit of a lisp to it but it was it
was okay like you know what i mean i
don't know it's just it was just a whole
i'm gonna plug the black cat people go
see the black cat boy yeah we did a
review of that a while back it's so it's
really good it's got both these guys in
it and [ __ ] they're both it's it's
it's their best work and they're both
they're the right age and the edit and
the way it's shot and the art and the
[ __ ] the script is really good
it's a [ __ ] good movie that's that's
the best movies that they that they both
did if you ask me they have a lot of
great they were in a lot of good movies
but when they were together that's their
best movie
yeah i think it's the best movie you
know what it's we should probably do
like a thing like all of lugosi and uh
lugosi and karloff's movies that they
did together yeah and see which one is
the best one i'm gonna say i've seen a
bunch of them and that's the one that
stands out i don't know the body
snatcher is pretty good too although
that was like that was like a later that
same one um
the black cap
and the raven the ravenness came on the
same vhs tape and i like and i liked the
black cat a lot better than the raven
isn't that the one where
boris karloff uh is he's a criminal he's
got to get his face changed
wait did that happen in that yeah and
and and and i haven't seen the ravens
he's kind of like a plastic surgeon he
could change the way his face looked
he was on the run and his yeah now what
black cat in the raven i think it might
have been a raven it's black and white
right
i don't know that's what it was maybe
maybe that's what like i said i haven't
seen the raven in a long time they were
poe i know that both of them had poe
titles but they had nothing to do with
the underground well i know the raven
had nothing to do with yeah they just
think that might be the same one because
they're okay so karloff isn't the
criminal on the run that needs to i
don't remember i haven't seen it in a
long time okay i haven't seen a long
time all right because i remember seeing
that movie but i get it confused with
like some other ones okay i'm not really
sure if that's the same one i thought
raven i thought the raven was more like
the comedic one that was more like a
like a thing that had because i thought
i had bella lugosi and boris karloff and
i thought that um
uh that [ __ ] was his name uh was peter
laurie peter laurie yeah yeah i thought
he was in it that's the color one this
is
black and white it's the same around the
same time that yeah christopher bell
said the raven is uh vincent price and
peter laurie yeah right yeah that's what
i was thinking it was the one that came
on the vhs tape that had the black cat
on it's a black cat and then there was
another
maybe it was pit in the pendulum
and it hit the car well the pendulum
just had vincent price in it that was
vince that was invented no this is the
30s okay it's black and white wait did
they make putting the pendulum back in
here it was black and white and it was
it had boris karloff bellagosi in it and
it had a poe title and it was one it was
made after the black cat
but only like maybe a year or two oh
[ __ ] man i can't remember which one i
don't know we might get into it but
let's uh all right yeah christopher bell
also points out carlos was a founding
member of the screen actors guild yeah i
want to get into that too because he was
like really instrumental in uh doing
that he was a very big advocate of uh
actors rights which you'll
find out why later on because of the
[ __ ] that happened to him
when he was like filming frankenstein
so uh so yeah
so he basically so he comes over to
canada
and uh you know starts working manual
labor and trying to get kind of like
acting jobs
so he
joins this company called the gene
russell company in 1911 and started like
touring all around canada in various
like stage productions and stuff like
that he also was doing manual labor on
the side like he worked as a railway
baggage handler for a while
and then he got another job with another
theater company that was in north dakota
and they had an opera house over like a
hardware store and they would like do
productions in there so he was doing
that kind of stuff so like i said it's
not like
he wasn't like an overnight success he
was he had been working and like doing
this kind of stuff like for most of his
20s and 30s he didn't really get famous
until he was in his 40s now um
because of the manual labor that he had
been doing in canada in the u.s like
trying to make money like while he was
trying to get his acting career
established
uh he actually got really bad
back problems and because of these back
problems he actually ended up not
fighting in world war one because he had
so many health problems
so uh boris karloff eventually uh made
his way to hollywood
and was in a bunch of silent films
usually as like in very very small roles
and
kind of in between he still had to keep
doing manual labor so he would like dig
ditches or you know just work on
construction sites that kind of [ __ ]
like in between because most of the
roles he had around this time period
were very very very small
um some of his early roles were like in
kind of cereals like he was in one
called the masked writer from 1919
uh he was in one called the hope diamond
mystery from 1920. there's like some
other ones that he was in around this
time period but like never any leading
roles or anything like that he usually
would get cast as you know exotic
foreigner type roles like bella lugosi
did uh you know he's arabian he's indian
he was he almost always a villain that
kind of thing
now one movie that he was in that
actually probably was i know
frankenstein was like his iconic role
but i think his breakout role where
people like noticed him was another
movie from 1931 that was called the
criminal code now this actually wasn't a
horror movie obviously was like a prison
drama
and he um he had actually played this
same part i think like in a stage
production and then he was like in the
movie and that actually like earned him
a lot of attention
that he was in this film
so uh
so i think that was kind of like what
maybe was instrumental in getting him uh
some work there was he was in another
movie too in 1931 where
he played it wasn't a main character but
he was like a supporting role and it was
a movie that was called five star final
and that movie actually ended up winning
uh the oscar for best picture that year
and because he was a supporting role in
it so that brought him some attention as
well it was called the raven
yeah that's what we said
okay i'm thinking of a different yeah
there's
1937. i'm thinking of like the later one
that they made
i'm thinking of the later one they made
so uh so yeah 1935. okay yeah so all
right from
from all of that
uh he started to get attention and so
they cast him as the monster
in frankenstein
and as i mentioned earlier when we were
talking about bella lugosi bella lugosi
later on said that he was the one that
recommended because bella lugosi like i
said was offered the role of
frankenstein's monster in the movie and
turned it down for whatever reason
and he said that he was the one that
recommended boris karloff too but i'm
not sure if that's true or not but
because the story i heard was that james
whale who directed frankenstein actually
saw boris karloff in
like the commissary like the um you know
the cafeteria or whatever and saw his
face and was like oh my god like i could
do so much [ __ ] with that face and so
that's how he got it but i don't really
know i don't know what the story was
everybody tells a different one
so uh so 1931 frankenstein james wells
frankenstein the classic came out and
that made boris karloff a
massive star like overnight
now
obviously the costume that he had to
wear uh they put four inch platform
boots on him and they had to bulk him up
so he was wearing like all this padding
and stuff so it'll make him look like
way larger
so um and also he had like all the
makeup they were putting on his face
like the iconic jack pierce makeup that
took about four hours to put on so boris
would have to get there at five in the
morning like to the set
and then uh they would put all the
makeup on every single day and then he'd
have to put all the stuff and there was
weights that was all kind of stuff
so uh the the shoes i believe what i've
heard like weighed 11 pounds each
so you know he had to kind of clomp
around in that stuff and i'm sure it
wasn't fun
so basically uh
yeah so
the
makeup on frankenstein was so iconic
that actually universal went out of
their way which i think i don't know if
this had been done previously but they
actually went out of their way to like
copyright
the
uh creature design and i don't know if
that had been done prior to this or not
but because it was so iconic and they
were just like yeah we don't want
anybody doing that that's why when you
see like later frankenstein movies you
can't do the same thing unless you like
pay universal because that's kind of
like their property so there's that
now a year after that uh as i mentioned
boris karloff also played impotep in the
mummy i haven't seen it jenny we gotta
see it i love them i haven't seen it
honestly like i said as awesome as the
makeup in frankenstein is um which is
amazing
but
i really really like boris carlos i
really like the makeup they did on him
in the mummy i think he looks super
super cool and i honestly really well
i'm into like mummy stuff and like you
know uh ancient egypt kind of stuff
anyway
so
i don't know i really really like boris
garlic than that and i'm not like saying
like because frankenstein is amazing and
i love the original i also want to see
manchu they said it's a great movie
that's [ __ ] weird as [ __ ] yeah that's
right yeah because he was yeah he was in
a bunch of stuff so yeah he was in the
mummy which again very iconic and that
whole like picture of him like as in oh
i love that [ __ ] i think that even looks
better than frankenstein uh but he was
also in another iconic uh old film from
this time the old dark house which also
had charles lawton in it and he was in
the mask of fu manchu which uh tom just
mentioned
so basically
yeah he was in all these like in within
like a year or two so
he's like an international star as i
mentioned earlier
it got to a point just within a year or
two where he was one of those guys where
he was just went by one name you could
just put karloff on the poster and
everybody would come see that [ __ ]
because he was like super famous so as i
mentioned even though i don't know why
but i always i guess because of
frankenstein i always perceived that
boris karloff was a way bigger
[ __ ] than bella lugosi but bella
lugosi apparently was six foot one and
boris karloff was five foot eleven which
like i said is not short but
i don't know that's it kind of like
upsets my whole weird
that's like a whole weird thing i always
thought boris karloff was way taller
than bellagossi but i guess not
uh so yeah so boris karloff was 5-11
so basically
karloff didn't have even though he got
famous
from frankenstein and the mummy and
stuff like that i think because
those two roles were heavily dependent
on makeup or like being you know very
obviously a monster
i don't think he got typecast in the
same way because if you're going to be
dracula i mean that's mostly you he's
you know dracula's mostly like a human
he looks like a human being whereas like
if you're frankenstein's monster stitch
together corpses and if you're a mummy
you're a mummy so it's just kind of like
there's a lot of makeup going on so i
don't think karloff got
he did like do a lot of horror movies
but i don't think he got typecast in the
same way that bella lugosi did and like
i said it's probably like luckier for
him that he was a native english speaker
so he didn't have that thick accent and
everything yes he had some other things
to overcome like he had a lisp and blah
blah but
it i don't think he had the same
obstacles to overcome that maybe bella
lugosi did and the thing about um
karloff too was that he had played
because he had played so many uh diverse
roles prior to frankenstein i don't
think anybody especially type cast him
in horror films even though he was in a
lot of horror films and he would always
kind of play those kind of characters
but he was pretty easily able to get
other roles
uh you know in genres other than horror
much easier than uh lugosi did and
another thing too somebody mentioned it
earlier he was actually in the original
scarface from 1932. so there was that um
and he played like a soldier in a 1934
movie called uh the lost patrol which
was made by john ford and he looks
actually great in that i saw like some
stills from it so that's kind of the
thing yeah mostly it was horror was his
thing but he was in like [ __ ] tons of
others don't forget his grinch stole
christmas yeah we're gonna get to that
we're gonna get to that
but uh so yeah and honestly as i said
because
bella lugosi had been sort of um he was
supposed to be the guy that was taking
over the mantle from lon chaney because
lon chaney you know obviously a fan of
the opera he was like you know made up a
thousand bases and he died
you know earlier than he should have so
they thought bella lugosi was going to
kind of like take that over that didn't
necessarily happen but
they had these two big horror icons and
they so they started putting them in
movies together and honestly it's just
kind of like i don't know if it's not
the same dynamic as you know your other
big horror pair up which is christopher
lee and peter cushing
it's not necessarily the same thing but
i man i always really really liked
seeing bella lugosi and boris karloff in
a movie together it's like i don't know
there's just such the chemistry between
them is different like i said than
christopher lee and peter cushing but
i don't know there was just something
really cool in the way that they like
worked off of each other
so uh so yeah the thing about it okay so
karloff was in frankenstein obviously
then he was in bride of frankenstein
from 1935 which is crazy because it's
one of the few sequels that people
actually say is better than the original
i don't know if i'd go that far because
they are different bride of frankenstein
is more black comedy but
i don't know they're both different but
i like them for different reasons
uh he was also in son of frankenstein
which he wasn't super excited about i
think he was in his 50s at that point
and i think at that in son of
frankenstein well actually in bride of
frankenstein i think they actually had
him talk and he wasn't really into that
uh decision because he thought that the
character was better if he didn't talk
but you know he still did it anyway
because you know everybody got to work
now son of frankenstein also had bill
lugosi in it so there's that now he was
also in another movie called house of
frankenstein in 1944 in which he played
the doctor more than like the monster
although he's not called dr frankenstein
i think he's called dr neiman but it's
kind of like the same situation
uh so he also played like some other
like mad scientist characters later on
like he actually did play dr
frankenstein in uh
frankenstein 1970 in 1958 and he
actually played the grandson of the
original creator so he was actually like
willing to
go with the mythos and like play some
other stuff
now here was another thing there was a
kind of a cheaper
studio called monogram pictures and i
think uh lugosi did some uh work for
them as well
so in the late 1930s boris karloff was
in some movies there as well now he
played a character named james lee wong
a chinese
detective obviously boris karloff is not
chinese by any stretch of the
imagination
but uh yeah he but he was in some and
like he said he played foo manchu like
earlier on but yeah he also standard
[ __ ] he played yeah he played a chinese
detective well that happened a lot like
but i'm not saying it's good i'm just
saying that happened a lot back in the
actors [ __ ] did any role you give him
pretty much yeah
all the way up to the [ __ ] 80s and
90s he did it
80s 80s pretty much oh yeah
tom uh
tom baker [ __ ] um
uh my favorite doctor who all right no
he didn't play it yeah yeah he did he
did [ __ ] um playing an arab
yeah [ __ ] uh send it in one of the
sinbad movies i think it was that 81
number 79 77.
it's just the way it was an actor would
could do any role i thought that movie
was earlier i thought it was late
sixties or maybe it could be early to
mid-sized community
oh okay yeah i remember we reviewed it
but i can't really hear it came out
uh
legendary7 says were christopher lee and
peter cushing acting together in hammer
horror movies from the very beginning
yes
um
actually the first hammer horror movie
and we actually talked about this
because we're going to put up a review
of horror of dracula
from 1958 like that's going up on friday
but the first hammer like uh remake of
like a classic universal movie which was
curse of frankenstein which came out in
1957 uh did have both christopher lee as
the monster and uh peter cushing as dr
frankenstein so yeah they were in it
from the beginning
we did a show about them like uh a while
back so
it's like i said it's a different
dynamic the two of them but
man they were always awesome i honestly
i kind of liked when they were
even though most of their movies they
were you know it's either dr
frankenstein and frankenstein's monster
or you know one's dracula one's van
helsing so they were usually like at
odds but i kind of like ones where they
work together too i thought that was
kind of cool because they seemed like
because they were friends in real life
which i thought was kind of neat but
i was kind of like that but lugosi and
karloff
i think i liked them better
i liked them better when they were
antagonists i think they played off each
other better as antagonists
but i haven't seen enough of it to know
that's what i'm saying but
i mean they were good either like i said
they were both amazing actors so
uh yes uh they said oh maybe that's why
the dynamic with bella lugosi and boris
karloff was different they each first
got famous independently that's probably
why like they weren't really like teamed
up i feel like peter cushing and
christopher lee
they
yeah they had like um you know careers
before that but
they were pretty much teamed up from the
beginning of the hammer horror cycle
whereas these two were kind of like they
were in their separate movies and then
people like the studios were like oh
both of these movies are successful so
let's put these guys together type of
thing there was that
so yeah so boris karloff did play a
chinese detective uh in a few movies
and uh for he actually like you know he
played frankenstein's monster a couple
more times the last time he actually did
the frankenstein makeup was in 1962
and they did a halloween episode of the
tv series route 66 anybody remember that
which also had peter laurie and lon
chaney jr on it because obviously lon
chaney senior was long dead by that
point
so um yeah so we're talking about the
movies that they did together like i
said the black cat which is your
favorite that was 1934.
they were also in several other movies
together including one called gift of
gab that was also in 1934 the raven from
1935 uh invisible ray from 1936 one
called black friday from 1940 another
one called you'll find out uh that was
also 1940 and the body snatcher from
1945 which i i really like the body
snatcher like i said i haven't seen it
yeah it's good i like it um he was also
in a movie called tower of london in
1939 with basil rathbone uh bella lugosi
wasn't in that uh he actually played uh
the henchmen of king richard iii so
there you go with that and he also uh
was kind of like did a british
intelligence kind of role like a movie
called british intelligence where he was
like a spy kind of movie
now in 1944 like i said and uh because
of all of the
uh stuff that he endured playing
frankenstein uh like i said all the
padding and the weights and the makeup
and all that kind of stuff
uh he had a lot of back problems
throughout his life not only from the
movies but also from all the manual
labor that he'd done like while he was
working his way across canada and the
united states so in 1944 uh actually
boris karloff had to have a uh spinal
operation because he had uh arthritis
like in his back
so in the late 1940s well mid-1940s
1940-1946 he was actually in some films
for rko which were produced by val luten
who also made some really good movies
particularly the 1940s cat people being
my favorite which is another one that we
should probably review uh that was one
of those was the body snatcher one of
those was called isle of the dead and
one of them was called bedlam and i
think that
he seemed like karloff really seemed to
be into these because they seemed like
more he liked like more higher end he
was a very educated kind of guy so he
liked the monster movies but i think he
wanted to do something more like
elevated horror a little bit and that's
kind of what these were so he was like
really into that
um
you know he's basically like yeah i was
in the frankenstein movies but i think
we've done everything we can do with
that and
he said he even said this is really
funny i found this like quote he's like
the last frankenstein movie that he was
in which is called house of frankenstein
he's like uh he called it a monster
clambake he's like he's like everything
was that frankenstein dracula it was a
hunchback there was a man beast it was
like it was too much
um and he thought it was like ridiculous
and he didn't want to do it anymore so
he wanted to do like he didn't mind
doing horror but he wanted to do
something that was a little bit more
like cerebral i guess because that's
what he's thinking about here imagine it
was kind of like [ __ ] okay this is
kind of like uh
what do i know exactly what he's talking
about let's put it in a different let's
put it in a different genre okay
kind of like how bruce lee was saying
martial arts [ __ ] suck there needs to
be a new kind of fight where you can
fight you know what i mean and get hurt
and [ __ ] and it is real fighting and
he was talking about mma
all right
what what karloff is talking about is
alien one and aliens that's what he's
talking about
alien one was [ __ ] cerebral and he's
also talking about [ __ ] like
he's talking about [ __ ] like vic and uh
uh
what was the name of it blade runner
pretty sure that's what he's talking
about but they just didn't have the
technology then
well that's and you know and i get that
because me like i said being a big
horror fan i look i love schlocky horror
i love gore i love all that kind of
stuff i love all kind of horror i'm not
picky
but my favorite stuff is more
like i said like elevated stuff i like
more literary stuff i kind of tend to
like stuff that's a bit deeper or a bit
but i like trashy [ __ ] too it just
depends on like what mood i mean i was a
kid when alien came out my dad took me
to see it theater there was nothing like
that back there that was state of the
art
it was like leaving the planet and going
to space
and seeing a real alien
so i couldn't understand these these
old-timey actors actors i can imagine
what it is that they're thinking they
could probably imagine stuff like that
but the budget wasn't there the
technology wasn't there didn't even have
color film yet
you know
but there's a bunch of [ __ ] that could
have been done that wasn't being done
well that's the thing and i kind of feel
like we brought this up a little bit on
our uh upcoming horror dracula review
where christopher lee i think even
though he likes playing dracula i think
he was always frustrated because he
wanted like i said he was more of like a
literary guy and he really liked the
book and so he really wanted something
closer to the book and so i think i kind
of he kind of got frustrated that it was
like kept getting farther and farther
away
like from the book like from the source
material and he's like i want to play
something like just like the book like
he wanted it more like literary but they
never really did yeah and
he's talking about a netflix miniseries
now i really wish they would kind of do
that although i kind of feel like i
don't know like dracula is so like
played out but
yes but it's played out but nobody
nobody has made
a [ __ ] dracula movie that's like the
book nobody
although somebody in the comments
mentioned that dracula untold is a good
modern it is
but that's more about vlad the impaler
right and the thing about it is that the
novel
i don't know it kind of like sort of
maybe backhandedly like hints around
that it's like maybe he's talking about
vlad the impaler but he doesn't like
mention that by name or anything like
that
inspired it's inspired by yeah so
you know so it's not crazy that like
films are saying hey he's talking about
vlad the impaler he probably was but he
didn't like overtly say that which would
piss off of volatkion because [ __ ] uh
prince vlad
draco of you know what is his name
what was his real name
prince vlad seppus tepid [ __ ] tapus or
seppish i've heard it pronounced either
way because they said that sometimes
that t is supposed to be silent
and uh he was actually a hero of velocia
they [ __ ] lost yeah they got statues
over there and everything okay he was a
badass he was just a military potentate
protecting the place from [ __ ] the
ottoman empire
and he did it by any means necessary
[ __ ] got job done you'd get impaled
okay if you came into his land and he
also zero tolerance for crime zero which
meant that you could leave a bar of gold
out nobody take it
because not only would you pay so with
your family so there was no stealing now
nowadays people go well you can't do
that well yeah you can he did it he did
it a long time ago uh would it fly today
not here
uh but you know that those days may come
again we'll
see but uh yeah okay i know i know what
they're talking about they want better
movies they wanted better movies they
wanted better scripts they wanted better
stories
go back look at that [ __ ] [ __ ] some
of them were good but man they're so
limited by the technology you know well
that's the thing it's just like any i
mean actors writers anybody like that
they're you know that's
you're an artist and you kind of want
so you kind of want like specific things
and you're not really getting it
particularly something that's i mean a
writer you can kind of do your own thing
because it's just you but when you're
working in film that's a very much a
collaborative effort so i can see how
it'd be frustrating if you're an actor
and you're like wow i really wish it
would be like this because everyone's
gonna see my [ __ ] face right like up
on the screen and i'm gonna get blamed
for this if it sucks so you know even
though it's not
necessarily you that's ruining it
after that haze code hit
everything got dumbed down those moves
are [ __ ] dumb because there's a bunch
of [ __ ] you couldn't do the bad guys
could never win
[ __ ] uh all evil had to be punished
so there's all kinds of [ __ ] hokey
[ __ ] you couldn't do a [ __ ] real
accurate story you know
imagine if you had the haze coast during
alien
yeah
and it would have never worked so much
that [ __ ] would have been thrown out
they couldn't have done it i kind of
feel like they weren't even really
allowed to do like nuance yeah until
like the 60s see it ended up being very
generic over and over again
and that's that's one of the reasons why
i got impressed by the black cat is
pre-haze code then that [ __ ] there's man
pushing the boundaries you're like yeah
okay
[ __ ] incest well not the incest but
necrophilia
implied necrophilia implied necrophilia
everything was implied yeah you gotta
they were classy about it
they
because they didn't get into dudes
private life
but what they're showing you that's what
it means you know what i mean just
you got to see it for yourself it's a
good movie it's classic to the whole
thing
but i think it made people mad they're
like that's just unacceptable
well that's what i mean it's cyclical
because back then they were just like oh
my god everyone's like degenerates now
like back in the 19 early 1930s and uh
all
all of the blame can be laid at the feet
of hollywood and like these movies
they're making everyone degenerate so we
have to kind of like take out all this
stuff because it's giving people ideas
look man
hollywood didn't make people degenerate
what made people degenerate was bad
writing
okay if you got good writing you can
tell any evil ass story as long as the
writing is good okay i'm the big
advocate of mediocre if the writing is
[ __ ] mediocre you could tell a good
story and it still [ __ ] you up
oh no no i'm just saying like you know
right and i'm not just saying that
because i'm a writer myself but writers
are kind of like the unsung heroes
that's where that's where the [ __ ]
story is coming from right
yeah y'all could [ __ ] it up like in the
bigger thing but it's like i kind of
feel like if you have a good script yeah
then that is that goes a long way
towards like making a good
yeah i'll i will kind of like
i'm going to say like and i'm not saying
that it's like yeah everybody has a role
actors cinematographers everything like
that but honestly if you have a shitty
script
um
you'd have to have really like
supernaturally good like uh actors and
cinematographers and stuff to overcome
that yeah also i will say on the back
end
uh editors editors unsung cameras of
hollywood so i'm gonna say writers and
editors don't get enough credit
all the people in between like the
director and the cinematographer and
actors they get cred they get credit but
i kind of feel like the writer at the
front end and the editor at the back end
i don't think you guys realize like how
much that [ __ ] has to do with how the
final product comes yeah
but i'm telling you what when it came to
those old movies that 1930-something
boris karloff bellagosi black cat that
i've been talking before had a fantastic
script and there's something missing
something got cut out of there
it has nothing to do with
edgar allan poe it's about a dude
who sacrificed his military unit during
[ __ ] the war
i think it was the austro-hungarian war
maybe
yeah he sacrificed him there to
consecrate the ground to build his
satanic temple the officer was a
satanist
boy man
you didn't hear stories like that for a
long long time
once that haze code was done you all
that [ __ ] stopped
and not in a credible sense
and a dude and poor and bella lugosi
comes out of a military prison called
the cool gaul and he was one of [ __ ]
hair shall mars [ __ ] men he's gonna
get vengeance and he also wants to know
what happened to his wife
because [ __ ] his commander stole his
wife
and [ __ ] they're up there in that
damn castle that he built it's a steel
and glass castle with sliding glass
automatic doors and an intercom system
and it's you know it's something that
back in the 30s you just you didn't see
it was [ __ ] decades ahead because the
course of satanist satanists has
superior technology it's just and then
all these rich people come for their
satanic [ __ ] rituals and [ __ ]
it's just just a badass script you know
and uh you didn't see things like that
at that level
after those haze codes started because
it was
they had to tone it down
they toned it down too much you know
but you could see which way it was going
you could see the way horror sci-fi was
going and it was going in a [ __ ] good
direction
because it was weird [ __ ] man but it was
stylish they knew what they were doing
i would
have they stopped or had they not had
that haze code it would have progressed
i think it would have we would have had
honestly probably we would have got like
genres we know nowadays we probably got
would have got that much earlier
right
because as it was now it's like
everything was kind of stymied right so
everything kind of had to go in another
direction
uh and then it wasn't really till the
60s or 70s where [ __ ] like really busted
and they really were worried they they
weren't they were worried too much
because the dudes were writing this [ __ ]
they knew what they were doing they you
know you they didn't really need to be
controlled it would it would have been
all right it would have been nothing
compared to what you saw today
uh
but but the writing would have been
better they knew how to write i mean
holy crap nowadays you guys
you can publish a book literally called
baby [ __ ]
and
it's fine
right yeah you could yeah and equality
could be bad and it would still be out
there i haven't read it i've just i've
just seen that because i've seen it like
on some other horror channels that like
they read it because it's like obviously
gonna be because it's called baby [ __ ]
but it's like now i kind of want to read
it because it's the title but you know i
mean
some gross horror [ __ ] and that's what i
mean it's like i'm kind of like
look and i will argue i don't think that
you should like sense or anything like
look you can write whatever shitty [ __ ]
you want i don't really give crap
write whatever you want um you know
nobody has to read it nobody's forcing
you to read it
to an extent i do like some extreme
horror
but i do kind of feel like there's a
fine line between i'm writing extreme
horror to like push the boundaries of
what's acceptable which is good we need
to do that
or i'm just writing [ __ ] up [ __ ]
because i'm an edge lord that wants
attention you know what i mean it's a
very very fine line right
so i kind of feel like
yeah because
no matter how it was going you never
would have saw some [ __ ] like human
centipede until [ __ ] way later anyway
you weren't going to stop the [ __ ]
prog the march of [ __ ] the time you
know what i mean our imagination was
gonna happen
but here's the thing
i liked human centipede i i liked the
first one yeah i never really could have
done without the sequels i never really
finished the second one it got too
boring and i just like i [ __ ] made
two or three different runs on [ __ ]
human cena beat too yeah couldn't get
through it but human centipede one it
made me feel very uncomfortable so you
know and that's what so it did its job
it was supposed to do that you know i
mean i was like yeah okay it's a good
movie and they were having fun making it
i could tell you know
and it was troll it was a troll they
were [ __ ] trolling your ass trying to
see how much they could get away with to
make you uncomfortable it was a story
they figured it out they thought about
it
like i said think about i don't know
like i figured it all out i have like a
weird relationship like i like a lot of
extreme horror
but i don't i like it if you're using
extreme horror to like say something
i don't necessarily like it if you're
just trying to be like hey look at me
like look how edgelordy i am you know
what i mean if he was that it was and
yeah and i kind of making you feel
uncomfortable
which okay fine
it worked it takes a lot to make me it
made me feel very uncomfortable it takes
a lot to make me feel very uncomfortable
although i will say i don't i don't like
the whole the pooping thing well of
course it was meant to make you feel
uncomfortable i felt very comfortable
like i can watch
any like pretty much anything and it
doesn't really bother me all that much
and i'm not saying that to be a badass
i'm just saying the one in the back
starved to death right yeah that was
some [ __ ] but that's the thing it's
like and like the second like i can
watch gore all day long you can pop out
people's eyeballs you can do like i
don't really care about that yeah but
the second you start like pooping in
people's mouths or like vomiting and
then drinking it or something like that
then i'm going to be like i'll watch it
but i'm just kind of like ah god damn it
i don't i don't like anything evil
scientist scatterfile [ __ ] joins all
these people together into a human
centipede and [ __ ] the one in the
front is trying not to [ __ ] let
everybody down for a long time it's
[ __ ] funny it's not funny all right
because he's just a duck that that would
really suck if that happened to you in
real life yeah he's got them all sewn
together which i can't help but i know
it's like funny it's like a funny
premise
but you know they were laughing when
they came up with the idea i'm sure they
did but then they weren't though because
we're still talking about it yeah but
then they're making the movie and then
they're trying to say we're going to
[ __ ] them up when they see this movie
and it worked it worked for me
you know what i mean
and it worked because i remember in a
way i don't know like i don't know if
this makes me like the worst horror fan
or the best horror fan because i'm so
i'm so empathetic that the first thing i
do is like is think to like what would
it be like to actually be in that
situation myself or see like my loved
ones like in that situation yeah so
you'd think that that would make me not
want to watch it because i'd be overly
sensitive but it's actually like the
opposite and i'm not really sure i can't
explain it you're a psycho i can't
explain it
all right i own that
[Laughter]
we gotta get back to this you say that
like an insult but it's not i smell a
chicken down there and i gotta [ __ ]
make sure that they're there yeah flock
of cigars
yeah yeah i got them africa yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah they're on it's tom six
edgelord like a little bit that's the
guy that made human centimeters yeah a
little bit
um
like i said i'm not real into like poop
stuff because it's just seems like
that's
it seems like easy it's an easy way to
like grow somebody out everybody's
grossed out by poop except for maybe
like a small percentage of people which
i'm not judging but i'm just saying that
most people are grossed out by poop and
vomit
so
if you're gonna put that in a movie yeah
it's gonna gross people out it grows me
out uh maybe gag so there's that but
i don't know i don't mind that and i
think there's a place for it i wouldn't
say like oh you shouldn't make that or
it's like make whatever you want i don't
give a crap like and i'll probably watch
it but
i mean for me like stuff that's more
scary for me or stuff that's more
effective for me
is
i want to see somebody make some [ __ ]
that's scary without like scary or gross
without having to resort to that you
know what i mean
to me that i think that takes a lot more
talent
but i'm not [ __ ] on like
exploitation books i love those too so i
don't know i like it all i'm not like
super picky
uh yeah oh on the topic of poop in the
mouth i see you talked about mad god
after what you read yeah we just watched
that not too long ago on i i really
liked it but you know so there's that i
just yeah i'm not i'm not really into
like the pooping thing and i
i've kind of thought about because i do
book reviews too and i've have
touched on a couple of kind of extreme
horror like i talked about um that book
that infamous book cows
by uh matthew stoko i think is how you
pronounce his last name which was
pretty [ __ ] gross it's not like the
grossest thing i've ever read but it was
like pretty [ __ ] gross like some
pretty [ __ ] up [ __ ] happened in it but
again it kind of just it really wrote
that line between i'm like reading it
i'm like i like this but
is the dude just trying to be
edgy
like just coming up with all this gross
[ __ ] just to be edgy like it's really
really hard
balance to strike which is kind of why
i'm very
ambivalent like about
uh extreme horror in general because i
feel like a lot of it is just people
going i'm gonna think of like the most
[ __ ] up [ __ ] i can think of like
you know
it's like a serbian if i'm gonna rape a
baby you know what i mean it's
you know it's like that and i thought
like a serbian film i thought was a
little bit edge lordy you know what i
mean yeah it's disturbing but i was just
kind of like it seemed a little i don't
know it seems a little try hard and i
don't really like tryhard i kind of like
if you're gonna make something
disturbing just make it disturbing like
don't resort to
the easy
pooping in someone's mouth that's easy
everyone's grossed out by that everybody
so
try to do something else to disturb me
but i'm not [ __ ] on that i'll read
it but
i'm just saying
all right so let me get back to boris
karloff because i'm almost done and
then we got to eat because i'm kind of
starving
so
again we talked about this a little bit
when we were talking about bellagosi i
kind of feel like boris karloff was
luckier in the regard that he actually
had a really long career like he never
really had
i feel like he didn't really have a
twilight period it feel like bella
lugosi was like super famous for like a
little while like a couple of years and
then it seemed like a couple years after
that like it was poverty row and he was
just like in these shitty
like [ __ ] z-grade pictures where i
feel like boris karloff never really had
that happen because you know he was in
good films pretty much all the way up
and then he went into tv and then he
would like parlayed into stage like he
went back into stage work and stuff like
that so and he really never seemed to
be
and i hate to use this term because i
don't really want to apply this to bella
lugosi because i love bella lugosi but
he like boris karloff never really had a
period where he was like a has been
quote unquote and that might have been
because
one he was older when he got famous he
was already in his 40s when he was in
frankenstein uh and he'd already kind of
like paid his dues i guess like he'd
already been in a bunch of like
like smaller roles like in films earlier
so as he got older he almost became like
an elder statesman
so he was in that and he was able to
parlay that into
like a really successful career like
until pretty much until he died to be
honest because even after all of the
movies
dried up a bit
um he would go on radio shows like he
was on uh lights out which was kind of
like a big radio show back in the day
um he would do like horror spoofs on
like the jack benny show and stuff like
that
um and he had his own radio show in the
late 1940s
uh he had a show called starring boris
karloff and you know and then later they
did the like a television series of that
like for abc
so
he really didn't ever lose any respect i
feel like
um he also i thought this was very funny
so as i said he kind of started out like
a like bella lugosi did on the stage
so he was in a production in 1941 of
arsenic and old lace
now the character that he played in
arsenic and old ladies and he had i
think he won a tony for this as well
arsenal lays there's a character in it
that's again that's a murderous gangster
that keeps getting pissed off because
everybody [ __ ] that he looks just
like boris karloff so the fact that they
got actual boris karloff to play this
character in this play was [ __ ]
genius and everybody loved it and it was
like a big huge thing like he really
like i said i'm pretty sure he got a
tony for that um or
i don't know if he got a tony for that
but he got a tony for another one he was
in another play where he uh was in a
play about joan of arc like he played
the the guy that persecuted joan of arc
so there was that so he was like a
really respected stage actor like after
that
and then after that he moved to
television now if you guys don't know i
have another channel called the scare
salon and
a couple weeks back
i have started to watch boris karloff
the boris karloff hosted series called
thriller from the 1960s
where it was like a horror anthology it
actually started out as a suspense more
of a suspense crime anthology and then
segwayed into horror later on
um but boris karloff hosted it and i was
like really interested in watching it
and it's on um i can't remember what
streaming service it's on but i started
like watching it
it's on 2b or voodoo or something like
that and so i started watching it and
i'm so i've been doing like reviews of
them like six episodes at a time so just
like a couple weeks ago i did like the
first six episodes because i love boris
karloff and i wanted to see he's not in
any of the um episodes at first he's
just like the host but he's in some of
the ones later on so yeah so he had like
whole tv series and he was in um so yeah
he was in thriller like i said uh he was
in one called out of this world there
was one called the veil which actually
was lost for a long time and they
actually rediscovered in the 1990s and
then he was in some roger corman aip
pictures uh the raven like i said i was
thinking of that one when you were
talking about the raven the one from the
1960s he was also in uh the terror which
was actually the first i think it was
jack nicholson's first role when he was
really young yes and the comments are
saying no raven was later on no there's
more than one raven yeah i was thinking
of the later on i was thinking of the
roger corman the 30s raven was boris
karloff bellagosi
yeah because right after black cat
because boris karloff was also in the
60s one that's why i was confused that
was like the the roger corman they were
one i remember the the 30s raven being
pretty good but not as good as black cat
that baby is another one that we want to
see but yeah so yeah so he was in uh
like i said the terror that had jack
nicholson in it uh he was in die monster
die he was in the sorcerers with
somebody brought up earlier that was
1966. he was also on like british tv so
he never really had i guess like a
twilight of his career he was pretty
much like working like all until he was
old he was and he was on like a bunch of
like uh panel shows like game shows and
[ __ ] like that
um
and you know he would be in a bunch of
parodies he was on man from uncle or no
girl from uncle uh he was in drag in
that one
uh he was on wild wild west like playing
in indian maharaja that was that
um you know so there was that now
in the 1960s mid-1960s as tammy brought
up earlier uh oh is it pookie
it's
look at the camera she's like daddy
i don't want to daddy daddy i got to
play with things on the floor
yeah go ahead yeah
she's like uh she's like doing her head
like no no no no no why are you why are
you picking me up and then she goes over
there to the damn cat dip
okay all right
yeah thomas swafford said
karloff was also an inspector march of
scotland yard of british television
series yeah i was gonna like i had that
in my notes right there
so yeah he was in [ __ ] like all the time
now in the mid 1960s i kind of feel like
he got
um
like a big career surge
because of as tammy mentioned earlier
how the grinch stole christmas the dr
seuss adaptation which [ __ ] man people
still watch that at christmas time
nowadays and that was what 50 60 years
ago holy [ __ ] the song that was a long
time ago now see the thing about it the
song though yeah i kind of feel like
people thought that was boris karl of
singing and it's not it's not no sounds
like you that's what i'm saying a lot of
people that that was actually a dude
named ravenscroft which what kind of
name if that's an awesome name but yeah
so um that was an american guy but he
was saying that but a lot of people did
associate because you know boris carlov
had that distinctive voice and he he's
doing a karloff impression yeah
yeah i don't even know if he meant to
but that's how it people did think but
it was a different guy but um yeah he
did do the voice for that
like the voiceover and so he got like
hugely famous from that and
jumping off of that
he also got a bunch of work
doing
um like reading stories for kids like i
even saw earlier on youtube they had
like a [ __ ]
clip from a show that he used to do like
children's stories with uncle boris or
something like that and he wasn't
like being scary or monstrous or
anything he was just sitting in a room
like masterpiece theater like reading
children's like red riding hood and
stuff like that to little kids with his
cool ass voice
so i kind of like that's kind of awesome
i just kind of feel like he didn't fall
into the same trap unfortunately that
bella lugosi fell into like i you know
he he actually was able to like
diversify out and do stuff for kids like
later on because he wasn't all that
scary so like i said somebody mentioned
that he was in the movie targets uh by
peter bogdanovich that's 1968
and he was also in a british movie
called the crimson cult
which i think was the last movie that
was also in 1968 i think that was the
last movie that would came out like
while he was still alive now he was
actually in a few movies after that but
they weren't released until after he was
dead he actually did some movies in
mexico
uh some of them were called the snake
people one of them was called that uh
the incredible invasion whoa it's
incredible fear chamber and housing
about evil
i guess
were they in the english or they are
they in spanish i'm imagining i don't
really know they said that they shot his
scene separately like they shot his
stuff in la like in 1968 and then they
finished them in mexico so i'm assuming
for spanish language so i'm guessing
that they probably dubbed him which is
kind of a shame yeah um i don't know if
he could speak spanish or not i don't i
don't know probably not um so yeah so a
lot of those and he did another one that
was shot in spain called cauldron of
blood
um so
those movies were actually released
after he died so the crimson cult as far
as i know was like the last one that was
released that he was in while he was
still alive
now the thing about it like while he was
working on these last movies uh boris
karloff had really bad emphysema
he only had
half of one lung damn that was still
working a quarter of all so [ __ ] man he
must have been smoking his entire life
yeah he had to like they would do a take
and then he'd have to go over to the
oxygen tank like that and get him there
which holy [ __ ]
um yeah so there's that
so i also mentioned earlier that he
edited a bunch of like uh books like
horror anthologies like he did that as
well so his name was big enough to get
into that and as someone brought up
earlier he was actually one of the
founding members of the screen actors
guild because of the [ __ ] that he had
gone through on the frankenstein movie
where he actually had some kind of like
lingering
physical effects from all of the uh
stuff that he had to do for that movie
he um
was kind of like a big advocate for
actors rights and for them having a
union and everything like that so he was
actually one of the founding members of
that of the screen actors guild so he
was really passionate about it and he
was like one of the instrumental guys in
like getting all of that started so
that's pretty cool as well
because
he thought that
because of the [ __ ] that they made them
go through back in the old days before
there was a union before there was rules
before there was all this other stuff
they'd basically like hey we're gonna
put like a 400 pound thing on you and
like make you work for
12 hours like and not let you go to the
bathroom or anything like that so he's
like yeah that shit's not cool uh so
yeah so he like i said he was very
instrumental in starting that so if you
remember the screen actors guild then
boris karloff is one of the people you
can uh thank for that because he was one
of the guys that started it
now uh much like bella lugosi he also
married five times which is crazy so did
bella um and also had one child also
bella lugosi belle lugosi famously
married five times and had one kid a son
uh boris karloff actually had one
daughter named sarah karloff and if you
see any uh documentary about him she'll
usually be on there talking she seems
like a lovely person uh and the daughter
was also by his fourth wife just like
bellagose was
um so yeah he apparently the the story
was that when his daughter was born he
was filming son of frankenstein and had
to rush over to the hospital with all
the makeup still on [ __ ] he must be in
his 50s or 60s when the daughter was
born then in it
i think he was 56 56 yeah yeah i think
his wife was somewhat younger but oh she
had to have been but yeah but because
she had a menopause because she had
again postmenopausal probably been in
her 30s or [ __ ] 20s
but yeah because like i said but both of
these guys really didn't get famous
famous until they were older i kind of
feel like he was 43 i know that for sure
i can't remember how old bella lugosi
was when he was in dracula but
he wasn't young because a lot of the um
uh publicity stills that i saw bella
lugosi were from his stage work when he
was younger
but most of the stuff from like the 30s
when he was in dracula and everything
like that he obviously looked like he
was already like in his 40s probably
so makes sense because
the audience has no memory of them right
being younger so there's nothing to
associate them with with another time or
other roles he appears as a heavy yeah
in his
40s or 50s
as a as a villain a heavy character or
something you know what i mean so
yeah it makes sense it's probably a
pattern i'd have to look at i don't if
you had if you had a role in your youth
and it was remembered back in those days
you probably couldn't make a transition
into a heavy character
because they were like yeah i think
people were lucky
what we can't be a vampire you know
there's gonna be something like that
buckwheat the favorite yeah
thank you stymie did something bad no
you know it's gonna be some [ __ ] like
that i would have watched a whole movie
about spanky yes
by the time they had the [ __ ] budget
to do spanking those guys those kids
were so played out i remember when i was
a little kid in the 70s they showed up
on talk shows they were played out that
they were still wearing their [ __ ]
crazy little hats so you could recognize
them and [ __ ] [ __ ] poor guys
i don't know if i would wanna i don't i
don't know if i would want to do that
they were like whatever happened to baby
jane actually they were doing that's
what i mean that's like to me that seems
like
i well but then i can understand like
being a child star that really does kind
of [ __ ] you up
in some ways i kind of feel like maybe
the reason and maybe it's because it's
horror to you which i think is a lot
more forgiving genre yeah because you're
not dealing with reality necessarily um
so i think that horror is a lot more
forgiving of like older actors but the
fact that both of these guys were
kind of paid their dues
on the stage and in smaller roles and
stuff like that when they were younger
and then by the time they got famous
they were already in there they were
already in their 40s yeah so everybody
just kind of got used to them so nobody
got used to them being like
really young and
dashing and whatever it's like everybody
just saw them as they were and it's like
they were kind of willing to take you
young people you didn't know what i'm
talking about i'm talking about little
rascals or our gang we grew up and they
were playing that [ __ ] [ __ ] i mean
that commercial way before our time it
was before our time that was 20s or 30s
30s i guess yeah that was actually
before my
grandmother's time to be honest but they
would play our gang you can see it all
free on youtube which is fun i went back
and watched them and no they stand up to
the test of time they're still funny
they're still funny
now as it went on it got
more canned
but early our gang was funny it was just
kind of like reality tv [ __ ] they
would take these little kids from the
30s and [ __ ] put them together and
they would interact and they were kids
from the la area and then kind of edited
it together into some just funny
adventures that they did and spanky was
the funniest time yes the main
first started the main ones
was [ __ ]
stymie
he was a black kid
with a [ __ ] derby on
spanky was a little boy he was a baby
and when it first started
uh i think alfalfa was walking around
though
and then you had
who else
what were the main ones in the early
part
but it was just
and then then spanky got a little bit
older and he could talk and [ __ ]
and
a lot of it was [ __ ]
stymie and spanky trying to get food at
the local [ __ ]
not really a bar but didn't have fast
food back then in south america would be
called a lunchio nachi which is like an
open
place where you had bar stools in a bar
you could get sodas and sandwiches
and um the luncheonette
they're in there trying to talk their
way into some food this is all
depression-era [ __ ]
and uh no man they were great they
edited it together and it was all
ad-libbed
and they were all
selected for being funny and kind of
like
high iq
and
stymie
spanky
and alfalfa were the main ones they were
high iq little kids
most of them ended up [ __ ] bad
ended up [ __ ] coming to bad ends i
kind of feel like alfalfa got the worst
alfalfa got shot and killed over a dog
fighting during a fight over a dog
in case you didn't know yeah stop stymie
ended up being basically a
bitter bitter old man
out in the hood unappreciated
you know he could have been a lot more
than he was time wasn't on his side
evidently [ __ ] drugs may have had
something to do with it
spanky was the one that kinda
ended up having a normal life but he was
just a little short fat guy
um darla darla crane ended up being a
u.s senator she was a little love
interest little girl she was cute she
could sing it's kind of like a
kind of like uh
what's a little girl that could [ __ ]
sing and dance back in those days
shirley temple kind of like a shirley
temp little brunette shirley temple type
and there was a bunch of other little
kids that kind of came and went
out but see there's something to be said
i think that i would rather
get famous a little bit later
yeah and i cuz i kind of feel like if
you're famous when you're a kid yeah it
usually doesn't work out well for you
now some people have had it work out
like jody foster that worked out okay
like but usually she had it rough though
too for me she did but that's what i'm
saying but she was famous later on i
tried to kill the president behind jody
i know
but i'm just talking about fall i'm just
talking about her career-wise i'm not
talking about like what that
[ __ ] did that wasn't her fault
yeah no but um she didn't even know that
career-wise she actually like did she
started out as a kid but actually she
was able to parlay into like a very
successful career as an adult that
doesn't usually happen i kind of feel
like it's usually better
it's probably better if you get famous
when you're a little bit older like i
said because then nobody's used to
seeing you as a cute little kid or like
a perky little 19 year old and then
suddenly like you're an old person and
everybody's like ooh age gross and then
like but if they already see you as
somebody that's you know in their 30s or
40s already then you aging isn't going
to be quite as drastic
and you're not going to be associated
with
uh being a cute child and now you're no
longer a cute child i kind of feel like
that's a word so i can see why a lot of
child actors like end up uh coming to
bad ends because a lot of them do
another r gang icon with buckwheat
eddie murphy who's my my favorite
comedian that i grew up with one of my
favorites [ __ ] going all the way back
to them
like in
favor of the hills cop the beverly hills
cop series and
and [ __ ] everything else you know
like a vampire in brooklyn and [ __ ]
he would was on saturday live he was
doing buckwheat impersonations a [ __ ]
buck
buckwheat was a little black kid from
the la ghetto
the old la ghetto from the 30s
wearing his sister's clothes and the
little [ __ ] cornrow type haircuts and
[ __ ] and he did all kinds of funny [ __ ]
and it [ __ ] if you're young man go
and go on youtube and watch
our gang also known as the little
rascals
and um
we used to watch it in the morning you
know we're eating cereal and [ __ ]
and everything in those old
old [ __ ] little shorts that they made
they showed them before movies there was
no tv then
still kind of stands it's kind in terms
of like
the moral the morals and the lessons
behind them they were good
and they were [ __ ] funny
little spanky punching grown men in the
face and [ __ ] and it was all ad-lib they
made that most of it the early [ __ ] that
was just all ad-lib they made it up as
they were going on it was kind of like
reality tv it was funny
close as you were gonna get to the
reality tv would have me rolling when i
was a [ __ ] kid and it had everybody
else rolling back in the 70s we would
laugh at that [ __ ] even though it was
old back then
it was old back then it was yeah like i
said that was way before our time
[ __ ] funny music and [ __ ] let me get
into okay so boris karloff like i said
he actually got bronchitis in 1968 and
got hospitalized and died of pneumonia
in 1969 he was 81 years old
uh and actually boris karloff i don't
know if you guys know this but he has
two stars on the hollywood walk of fame
one for his movies and one for his tv
uh
legendary seven said is it true that
when he was in horror bella lugosi was
still accustomed to thinking of himself
as young and dashing an old a e show
seemed to portray in that way i'm not
really sure i don't know like i haven't
seen that um
documentary that you're talking about
but
i don't know i think that he did
i don't know after he came out of rehab
when he was like old
i think he realized because man he
looked bad like when he came out of
there they took pictures of him like i
said he was
open about it so i guess he was okay
with yeah you can publish pictures of me
looking like
this
um because he really didn't look like he
was in good shape because he was trying
to like you know be honest about the
addiction and everything like that but
i don't know maybe up until
a certain time he did think of himself
that way because like when he was
younger he absolutely was a ladies man
and he
got um
you know he was kind of seen around town
it's like oh with all these big ingenues
and big stars and everything like that
so he was kind of seen in that way and i
think for a long time he did kind of
consider himself that way but
once he got
past a point
where he was just like in
shitty poverty row pictures all the time
i think he probably like wised up and
was like yeah i'm not really
what i used to be which like i said is
sad because
the same thing didn't happen to boris
karloff you know what i mean boris
karloff was able to
and i don't know if it was necessarily
just anything to do with them i think it
was just kind of to do with the system
as a whole
but boris karloff was actually able to
parlay into like kind of being an elder
statesman kind of thing and he i don't
think he ever lost respect or he never
yeah he was in maybe like a couple
cheapy [ __ ] shitty movies but he had a
back catalog of him being old so yeah he
didn't really
he didn't really fall into the same and
you know it should be said too he didn't
get into drug addiction he didn't like
to so he was actually he had like a lot
like health problems obviously but
you know he was able to kind of like
keep going and keep his dignity i guess
somebody mentioned robert blake was also
a little rascal and i gotta say my mom
dated robert blake
somebody set her up on a date back in
the 70s with him
she thought he was nice but she she
didn't like him she thought he was too
old back then i which would in the 70s
he would probably have been in his
[ __ ] 50s probably
40s or 50s she didn't like my mom was
probably in her twenties
but uh no [ __ ] yeah robert blake my
mom dated him that's pretty funny yeah
tammy says ron howard was the best kid
actor to grown mature adult still
directing yeah that's right ron howard's
still around and like i said he was yeah
you know he was in
he i think it was better that he
parlayed more into directing because
that would seem like more of what he
wanted to do anyway more than acting
thomas wofford said 2020 embarrassed
themselves when they did a segment on
what happened to stymie they interviewed
a guy who claimed to be him and wasn't
it wasn't him several people lost their
jobs everybody hey when's diving i think
i kind of remember like hearing that's
funny i didn't know about that yeah and
then they're talking about i was sure
that stymie just was ended up being a
bitter old man didn't want to do
interviews
in a very low income house
out in the middle of the hood in l.a
that's how that's the last time that
makes me like so sad because it just
kind of feels like
because of the nature of
movies right like you know all of us are
still watching buckweed and stymie and
stuff like that as they were back then
and you don't really when you're
watching it you're just kind of like
enjoying it you don't really feel like
what happened like what happened to that
dude like later on and it's just like
i'm sure like the money for that like
dried up in like five seconds somebody
mentioned that [ __ ] uh that that
eddie murphy on saturday night live did
a buckwheat guy shot video i remember
that and they did it like it was a news
report
but we got shot yeah yeah i remember
that that [ __ ] i remember being [ __ ]
funny
uh i imagine you could probably get a
saturday night live eddie murphy [ __ ]
greatest hits of all the [ __ ]
funniest
hilarious remember the time when eddie
murphy did white face
and [ __ ] impersonated a white person
to see what the world was really like
and he goes up on the bus and when the
black people leave they pull out the
hors d'oeuvres and they start [ __ ]
hand and wine around all the white and
all the white people on the bus are
having as soon as a black person shows
up they [ __ ] hide all this [ __ ] again
it's just funny man look at eddie and
eddie's there [ __ ] white face going
like
the world's a lot better [ __ ] when
he's in my face and [ __ ]
white people are secretly helping
themselves no you have to worry don't
don't don't pay for it somebody got she
goes up to buy some big item and [ __ ]
and [ __ ] he goes in the kitten he
didn't have enough money and
the cashier is like
don't worry about it just take it
let me tell you black people that
doesn't happen okay we still gotta pay
for [ __ ]
[ __ ] funny although y'all could be
forgiven for thinking this yeah
yeah you might think that happens that
doesn't happen i wish it happened i
don't have to pay for anything
uh tammy said robert blake uh has a lot
of mental problems yeah dad treated him
so bad when he was little yeah
i mean you know my mother's friend and
and uh introduced them and kind of set
them up he was looking for a girlfriend
or something this is like back in the
70s after my mom got divorced
she went on a date with him and she
didn't like him
my mom was a hottie back in those days
every time i think of robert blake
nowadays i just think of i know i don't
think of like the the wife shooting but
i think of him from lost highway
yeah yeah that dude was a creepy
[ __ ] yeah yeah well and also i
think of him from uh in cold blood the
whole wife thing is is sus
but if i'm gonna call him out i gotta
call out shat because shat's wife's
situation was kind of suss too it was um
honestly i don't know i don't know if
lake had anything to do with his wife
dying i'm i'm neutral on that um but
yeah the whole william shatner thing i
feel like shaq gets a pass you got a
pass people forgot about that there were
some women i'm not saying that shat
murdered his wife i don't think that but
it's just some weird [ __ ] to have but it
was like a weird situation and i just
feel like people don't call it about it
people don't talk about it
to 9-1-1 they played it and it sounded
fake
my wife she's she's dead she's in the
pool
he was acting he was definitely acting
but see that's the thing i just the way
your voice sounds i don't know because
william shatner is so known for being
like over the top maybe that's just the
way he talks
and he can't
turn it off i don't know she was
definitely addicted to drugs
she definitely was found dead in the
pool
she drowned somehow
there was no signs of violence
you're never going to get a conviction
so
that's what i mean and that's the thing
about that um is that
you know yeah it's totally possible for
you to get like so [ __ ] up on drugs or
drunk or whatever that you could
absolutely drown in a pool like yeah it
happens
um
you know
yeah there was no proof of anything else
but it was just weird it was just weird
right
now the thing with there was no proof to
prove the [ __ ] uh what's his name
shot his wife he did not shoot his wife
somebody else shot him yeah now
yeah i don't think he shall robert blake
i don't think he should be someone now
did he pay somebody to shoot the wife i
don't know that's a different question
yeah uh but i don't think he did there's
no way his his gun was on fired and and
he was shot while his gun was in the
custody of the people that owned the
restaurant because he had a carry
conceal permit
and what she went out to the car was in
the car and somebody shot her while she
was out there it was la weird [ __ ]
happens that's what i mean it could have
been totally random could have been
random but nothing was ever taken yeah
that's another one it was just
like i said i don't know i wasn't there
so
like i know he didn't do it no but i'm
just saying you know obviously you got a
page
i don't know if he did that some people
surmised was that a hit because they
were fighting me but a lot of couples
fight
that's what i mean it's like it would
take a lot right
for you to pay actual money
to like have your significant other
killed
yeah i mean well la you know you know
the right guy just a certain amount of
drugs
[Laughter]
if that was a pro hit it worked
true you know
yeah it would have been a ghetto pro hit
didn't not not much money involved it
did work
i just there's just no proof if it was a
pro hit that's what i'm saying yeah
because i'm not coming down on one side
right legendary sevens also said people
also think robert wagner was suspicious
when natalie wood drowned i think we
talked about that i think we did a show
a long time ago about hollywood
mysteries and we talked about that
because christopher walken was there too
and i think the whole thing was
they thought didn't they think that like
natalie wood and christopher walken were
like having a thing or am i thinking of
the right thing yeah but yeah
so that that was super suspicious i'm
not accusing anybody but that was also a
very suspicious situation but i'm not
saying that like weird accidents don't
happen because they do
um but that's why cases like that are so
difficult because yeah it absolutely
could have been that it was just like
some bizarre like [ __ ] freak accident
yeah that's possible
same with shat and all those i mean but
i understand how like if the
circumstances are weird then yeah you
have to look into that [ __ ] because it's
absolutely couldn't have been an
accident it might not have been an
accident i must say that in certain
states those dudes would have went to
jail
well yeah some states like louisiana
you'd go to jail both of those dudes
would be in jail
if they if they weren't famous
they'd be like well being famous helps
oh yeah right being famous helps
you know i will say and having money
helps yeah obviously because you can
afford a defense because you know you're
it my broke obscure ass
uh you know if i was involved in
anything it's like you're suspicious i
was just guilty i would just get a
pretty guilty yeah i wouldn't wouldn't
if you don't have any money to accuse
you you're [ __ ] yeah i'm in trouble
yeah like i said
[Laughter]
i'm aware of that
so um
probably about time to shut it down yeah
i'm getting man that food is smelling
really good down there
and check on that and we haven't eaten
since god it's almost 10 p.m we haven't
eaten for almost 12 hours i'm going to
have a whole leg quarter do you want a
whole egg quarter sure you're gonna make
potatoes got the mashed potatoes ready
to go man make some potatoes yeah i
haven't eaten for like uh 11 hours at
this point we had we had lunch earlier
go ahead and shut it down jim all right
so hopefully you guys enjoy the show i
know we went off on a lot of tangents
but you know we do that all the time
anyway yeah so uh so yeah so be sure to
come by friday
because we don't know what weird cheap
ass or weird-ass liquor that we'll be
doing a taste test on but we'll find
something we'll go to the liquor store
we'll go to the liquor store like
tomorrow yeah maybe we'll go to the
liquor store tomorrow or friday we'll
like find some like weird maybe he'll
pick something i'll pick some uh but
yeah and tomorrow i'm gonna put up
another crime immemorial video it's
gonna be about
three murders that were possibly maybe
possibly cia related uh but maybe not
and i'm also putting up a review of the
2022 movie revealer because i know a
couple people uh asked about that
because it was on shutter so i did a
review of that i'm gonna put that up
tomorrow as well
so we will see you guys again on the
live stream on friday evening thank you
everybody for dropping by thanks for
your super chats we love you guys we
will see you again friday night bye